Hello, happy Christmas Eve, the day before Christmas.
But if you're in Asia right now, Merry Christmas to you
guys.
Happy holidays.
Hello, everyone.
So I thought I was almost done with this game.
So that's why people were like, wow, she's, I didn't realize
when I posted the schedule, people were like, wow, she is
very confident she's going to finish Hades 2 today.
And I'm like, why do you guys say that?
I don't understand.
I just have one more boss left.
in chat they're like good luck on your six runs and i'm like
what do you mean six runs and they're like oh i was like
excuse me but what do you mean i need to beat six runs i i
thought i had one more boss left so we're i will see if we
finished it we will beat i was i'm not sure now i'm not sure
i mean i do have eight hours until good night dragoons but
like this was today was not supposed to be the marathon
stream today tomorrow's the fucking endurance stream um yeah
i actually does she know like i definitely lack critical
information there i was like i i just get beat that what was
his name typhon or whatever the king of monsters and then we
should and beat up grandpa that's like two two runs i got
this and then someone's like oh yeah good luck we're trying
to get six runs done i'm like i tried yeah i got changes i
had to i tried a fish all right so i originally wanted to
stream yesterday because you know um you know yesterday and
the day before yesterday were not like the actual like
christmas holidays so like people would be were free around
those times um because like you know christmas eve christmas
uh is like you know the time to spend with your family and
friends and stuff like that um and so a lot of people would
be super busy and everything um so but i did a costco run
yesterday because i was worried i won't have food for the
next two days i i know i got worried i was like oh man will
i have food the next two days i should i should do a costco
run um because i was worried that like you know a lot of
restaurants won't be like actually i didn't want to eat fast
food and i feel like a lot of like the good restaurants
would be like you know uh you have to book it in advance or
like they won't be like in service so i decided to do a
costco run uh yesterday i spent a lot of money at costco
yesterday i haven't gone to costco in a long ass time it was
funny though seeing to the you know the the food section
like nobody cares about what the fuck is going on by the way
while i was doing the costco i i got a lot of food so i'm
like practically stocked for the next two to three months
they're all my top freezer is just packed with food now um
um but yeah so i put everything in the freezer so it'll last
longer um anyway yeah at least like at least a month i have
at least one to two months worth of food i spent a lot i
think i spent like like 300 to 400 canadian dollars i was
just like oh i want this and i want that i'm like oh this is
so good i'm gonna get this oh they have swedish meatballs
yeah i got some swedish meatballs and um i got swedish
meatballs i got uh ground beef i got um i got uh Some oven
chicken bites.
I got, um, I got some, I got some cheese.
I love cheese.
Average Costco run.
I forgot the worst part is that I forgot they don't give you
bags for your, um, they don't give you bags for whenever you
do Costco runs.
So it was really awkward to, you know, Uber in and out.
Oh yeah, I wanted to get the, I also got the classic
rotisserie chicken.
And I also got the you know the taco kit, too.
I got the taco kit.
I got the taco kit and also the rotisserie chicken and the
chicken salad Oh my god, because sometimes I would order
online For Costco, but every time I tried to I would try
they would have the rotisserie chicken But they won't have
the chicken salad because chicken salad is always sold out
whenever I try to order online So it's like it was so
fucking frustrating, but I finally got it because I was
actually there in person finally got my chicken salad anyway
uh yeah the taco kit so it comes with the the chicken the
the little uh the little tortilla wrap uh the uh the cheese
and then the cabbages um yeah i'm gonna survive canadian
winter guys i stocked up for winter a little too late but
it's okay i've got i i finally stocked up just a couple of
days before christmas yeah So, yeah, but someone was like,
yeah, but you got bought.
I forgot about the boxes.
So, um, it was a little awkward, like, taking the, because I
was like, all right, time to leave Costco.
And then the moment I was, like, like, heading to my Uber,
Uber driving, I was like, oh my God, wait, they didn't give
me bags.
So, I was just like, how the fuck am I going to carry this
back to my apartment?
Like, because it was just like a bunch of food.
Add no boxes.
It was just like, so I was just like, to the uber driver i
was like can you help like um i forgot to bring any bags or
boxes and like um can you help me bring it up to my
apartment door so we were just unloading back and forth like
to the elevator and then the elevator to my apartment door
and then i was like okay i i fucked up I mean that's I might
have fucked I was like I will give you a tip If you would
help me I'll give you a big tip If you would help me Unload
my groceries No I didn't even bring a little wagon I forgot
all about that I was just like I should get some food Before
the holidays roll in So I don't fucking stif Oh by the way
It didn't even matter Because I forgot I don't have baking
trays so i today today i uber eats baking trays because i
forgot to get baking trays because like i bought those like
oven uh prep meals um like the salmon with the little crab
cakes in the middle um and the bell pepper with the rice and
the uh uh and the meat and stuff and i was like oh fuck i'm
i don't have i don't have a baking tray how am I gonna put
this in the oven so today today before the store closes I am
uber eating um baking tray plus also I ran out of rice so I
got it I ran out of rice and pasta sauce so like my whole
plan like basically because like you know I would like to
have like something to go with my like my protein so I don't
have aluminum foil as well so so today i i thought i thought
my plan was solid so today i have to uber eats rice pasta
sauce because i have pasta i just don't have sauce with it
um and i could use like insta ramen but that's just a little
sad you know i've got i bought like like a 400 grocery bill
and i used fucking insta ramen uh with my food um so yeah so
i got i got some that for i knew i knew i should have got a
i knew i should have made a list i just went in there with
vibes i was like i i was like i i will feel what i need and
clearly vibes did not work out for me i should have been a
little more organized um anyway uh yeah never use vibe to
shop um also i was looking at pcs there holy but okay so you
know how there's a issue by the way um something came up on
my twitter but apparently it's cheaper to buy a gun than it
is to buy ram now which is a crazy statement to make but
it's true i saw a tweet that was like the fact that 64
gigabytes of ram for a gaming computer now costs more than
ar15 is pretty fucked up just like all back but i was
looking at like the pc section and it's so funny because all
the pc they were displaying um they took out the ram it
looked like they were people were worried that people were
gonna steal the ram in the pre-built PCs that were on
display because i was looking through it and i was like
where the fuck is the ram like the ram sticks were god and i
was And it was like the pre-built PCs were like $1,000 for
like 32 gigabytes of RAM.
And I was like thinking, oh my God, I could just buy this
pre-built PC, deconstruct, take the RAM, and then sell.
I swear to God, people are actually doing that in Costco.
Like they would just go to Costco, buy the pre-built PC,
stock up, like stock it up like Pokemon cards.
I swear to God, I am not the first person to think of this.
Like, stock it up like Pokemon cards, wait a couple of
months, and then sell the RAM out.
Big brain.
Bro, it was 32 gigabytes of RAM in the PC.
Okay, for $1,000 and you get a entire PC with the PC is
bonus.
The RAM is what you're aiming for.
Like, new scalping meta drop.
yeah i'm pretty sure people have flipped those pre-builds
before uh that's my retirement money i was like thinking
about it um yeah i'm buying the ramp and it comes with a
free pc anyway also very important announcement today um
that wanted to let you guys know about um so today in
fortnite they're dropping grute as a sidekick and also uh
there's also pulp fiction uh back to the future and also i
show speed is dropping today so i really needed to let you
guys know about it and you can use my creator code uh dokey
braid to get there's no discount but to get zero percent
discount but it will support me though it'll support
dokeybird you won't be giving majority of the money to
fortnite it was a very important announcement okay actual
real announcement oh yeah just funny zandu wished me a merry
christmas um this morning and i was like snow miku's in this
shop and he was like oh my god i'm gonna get it now
Christmas and I was like oh hey happy holidays Merry
Christmassy and happy holidays and I was like by the way me
by the okay but he messaged me when I was asleep though so
like I didn't know if he got it or not he just replied back
like I'm check I'm gonna open Fortnite right now so I don't
know if he got it or not he went on this I think he went
online just to wish me a Merry Christmas which is really
nice of him um because we haven't talked in a while since
like you know he's living his life and everything but it was
really nice that he went online just like went back like he
he's off the grid for those who don't know zandu is off the
grid but he did go back on the grid just to wish me a happy
holidays um and i had to update him a very important news
that uh snow miku is um is in the shop so i hope he did get
it um anyway actual important Tomorrow is the Christmas
party.
So for the Christmas party, I did post a schedule on Twitter
and a community post.
Let me put the schedule out right now.
Oh my gosh, I'm like stalling so much when I really need to
beat this game.
I have very limited time to fucking beat this game right
now.
So I did post a schedule, but here is a little schedule
reminder for everyone to look up.
It is on the YouTube community post and on Twitter.
Starts at 3 and potentially ends at maybe around 1 a.
I'm going to try and do an 11 hour stream.
I would do longer if my rest of the next two weeks is not
absolutely fucking packed as hell.
It is very packed right now.
So I was like 11 hours will be like the goal.
But I felt like 11 hours is pretty good for everyone around
the world to be able to drop by whenever they want.
and everything so uh from different times so it's being a
drop in and out whenever they can uh for the christmas
stream um so it starts at 3 p.m p.sc yeah i was gonna say do
i start at 3 i had to remind myself do i actually start and
then we have for the gaming with dragoons sections i did try
to pick games that are free to play um or like very cheap
you know some mind like people already have minecraft it's
pretty cheap and also a lot of people already have minecraft
accounts too like random you know like those like as random
smp servers that anyone can join and stuff like that maybe
we'll just like raid a server and just make it just like
raid some port guys for a server and be like play bed wars
or some shit we could do stuff like that um and obviously
this is a guideline not a not a strict schedule and uh so uh
we won't be following it to the t maybe we'll do something a
bit longer or do something a bit shorter maybe we'll pivot
to something else randomly maybe there will be another game
or another thing i want to do in the middle like that's
doesn't follow the schedule so it's like it's just a
guideline it's we're just vibes vibes will work eventually
um but we do have a guideline um so all of that uh also
we're going to do what's the word we're like is it the
honors code we're like um if uh you guys make sure to like
um if you do match join in a session for uh the gaming
session uh please for the next uh let other dragoons have a
chance to also play with me so uh try to aim for just like
yeah honor system we'll do it in honor system so let other
dragoons have a chance to play with me um because i want
everyone to have a chance to join in on the fun as well uh
yeah so we uh just like don't join in the next session if
you already played with me type deal um but in that that's
basically the guideline for uh tomorrow's stream um i know
like some of you guys are spending the holidays um alone so
um i hope this helps out with you know keep welcome here me
and the dragoons are all here to keep everyone company um i
usually i don't know if you guys know this um but i've said
this before a lot in past because i do do christmas streams
um but um i've never my family and i never really celebrated
christmas um and like ever since i was growing up so like
christmas is not like a very important holiday for me but i
know it's a very important holiday to a lot of people so
that's why i want to be here to like you know um spend time
with you guys and you know have a lot fun too uh it's like a
christmas spirit and everything uh f that i am double
tapping in camera thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you uh fistfoot they give a super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
And learn the Merry Christmas from SEA.
I'll be busy and I can't catch all the stream.
But I want to wish you and the dragons a happy holidays.
Try not to drink your voice too much, too.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much, Fistful.
But yeah, like I said, you guys don't have to know.
What's the word?
You're just sensitive to like try and force yourself to be
there for the entire stream.
Feel free to just drop in and out whenever you guys are
free.
Or if you want to stay for the entire stream.
um let's all have fun you know uh f1 welcome to tomato farm
welcome welcome yeah i think like in the past when i was
growing up the only thing i really did for christmas it was
we would have i think this is an asian thing but like i
don't know like a lot of asian people relate to this but the
the fucking christmas buffet dinners every time it's
christmas it's like my my Asian parents would be like this
is the the perfect opportunity to get a buffet yeah it's
like it's always a buffet it's always a Christmas buffet
yeah it's like this is the perfect time always the crabs hmm
that's usually like what my parents would always do for what
It's always my family as well.
Extended family as well.
What we'll always do for Christmas is just go straight to
the go for buffet.
Christmas buffet time.
To be fair, like the Christmas buffet is really fucking
good.
To be fair.
All right, what else?
What else do I want to guys update you guys about?
Let me double check before we...
Oh yeah, love the Christmas market.
Had a great time at the market.
bought a lot of stuff, ate a lot of really good food.
There was a line for these, like, what are they called?
They're like, I don't know what European country it is, but
it's like these cake cones.
And apparently it's like a traditional European snack, like
dessert, where the ice cream is in a cone that's like
basically made out of cake.
But I wasn't able to get it because the lines were way too
fucking long.
Like the chimney.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
It's called chimney.
I don't fucking remember it.
I was, I was eyeing it too for a long time.
I was like, ooh, I don't get it.
I was like, I'll come back when the line was shorter.
It's shorter.
The line never became shorter.
I came back every couple of, like, like every like 30
minutes or so.
I would come back just to see if you're like, oh, it's the
line shorter now.
It never became shorter.
And then when it was about to close the Christmas market,
the line, was still looping, and I'm like, okay, I'm just...
I'm just gonna leave now.
On Twitch, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Merry Christmas, Doki and Dragos.
Your Christmas trees are now part of my tradition for years,
and always a blast.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you've been joining all the Christmas streams over
the years.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, so I was very sad.
That was like one thing I was very sad didn't get.
I also got a lot of cool...
I bought dad a taco collar.
There was a little dog stall.
And they were selling like collars and bandanas.
And I found a collar that had tacos on it.
And I was like, I gotta get this for dad.
I really wanted to bring him to the Christmas market.
But like also there were a lot of children there.
And I knew he was, he does not fuck with kids.
So like I got, I for the safety of everyone.
I did not bring, I sadly did not bring him to the Christmas.
market there are also a lot of dogs too so i knew he would
does not fuck with that too he was like he would fight
everyone so so um so yeah i bought him i bought him a taco
collar it's really key i'll give you i'll show you guys a
picture later i didn't take a i didn't pick up take a
picture of it yet but whatever i do i'll show it to you guys
later uh yeah no he fucks with hot women or any women
honestly like he has no standards oh but like if they're
really pretty he like he he's more obsessive he likes all
types of women but the prettier they are the more excited he
gets same bro pulls instantly um twitch welcome to timidify
welcome welcome manny the u.s super chat But thanks for the
fun times that you're looking forward to more in 2026.
Have a good one.
Thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, almost forgot.
I am debating whether or not to do multi streaming too for
the Christmas stream Because like I said, you know, um, it's
for like all the dragoons out there who you know want some
company Um as a community and I was thinking like, you know,
usually I like I said, I don't do multi streaming But I
figure since it is a Christmas stream, I did debate whether
or not to do it Um, and like I said, I'm mostly um it's
going to be a lot of work looking at two chats but i figured
you know like since it's the holidays i figured it might be
a good time to try out multi-streaming but like i said it's
not like going to be a common thing i just thought it would
be a special occasion to do it just so uh you know uh keep
the dragons on both platforms like uh company as well um but
we'll see we'll see how i feel what do you guys think you
think i should do multi-streaming for tomorrow for the
Christmas stream a Christmas miracle it's my Christmas
miracle hmm go for it hell yeah yeah you guys can watch on a
item platforms if I do do um um if I do do like
multi-streaming for it uh Tamago think of a super chat thank
you thank you hi took you happy to with dragons for another
christmas day and also yesterday was my birthday so i have
to ask if i can get a happy birthday for you but in spanish
if it is possible tamar i i unfortunately i don't know what
happy birthday is in espanol but i can be like felice navida
whoa felice navida felice navida tamago felice navida it's
almost the same right like but happy birthday tamago now
announcing you in English one.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Tamago.
Yeah.
Happy birthday.
Please complain us.
Oh yeah.
Apparently like it's not pronounced tortillas.
Um, I have a friend that got really mad at me for saying
tortillas because it's supposed, you don't pronounce the L.
It's like, or is it tortillas?
I don't remember how I pronounced it.
I was like, I was like, oh, I love tortillas.
And they're like, what the fuck did you say?
I pronounce it like that.
Tortillas.
What the fuck did you just say?
Yeah, so I pronounced it tortillas or tortillas.
Is it both wrong?
Is it okay?
You're talking to a person who pronounced quesadillas
quasadillas for like seven years before I got to...
Are they...
Before...
I used to pronounce quesadillas?
Quasadillas.
Can I get some quasadillas, please?
Can I get chicken quasadilla?
Quasadilla?
Because I lived in Asia and no one corrected me when I would
ask.
for a chicken quesadilla and then when i got to university
as my friend and i were ordering at a restaurant and she was
like what do you want i was like i think i'm gonna get a
chicken quesadilla and then she was like um you mean a
quesadilla and i was like what what are you talking about
What?
No, no.
Isn't it quasadilla?
Sorry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Keep pronouncing like that because of the rage of hate.
Patrick, I said that you was super chat.
Thank you.
Don't keep being very Canadian.
I rarely eat Mexican food, but these chicken quesadillas
things ain't half bad.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Also, apparently in Canada, our chicken tacos ain't right.
So the tortillas, the tortillas and the tortillas, they're
white.
And like, apparently they're not supposed to be white.
Like, that they're supposed to be yellow because I was like,
what do you mean?
My, like, I was like, I was like to one of my friends.
I was like, look, I bought chicken tacos, the taco kit.
And, and, uh, and ours is white.
So, like, in Canada, they're white.
And, uh, and then, um, one of my friends were like, what
the, why is it white?
And I was like, what do you mean?
So, apparently, um, They're supposed to be yellow because
it's like a different ingredient or something.
Yeah, like the traditional is like corn or some shit.
So that's why it's yellow.
But like in Canada for Costco, ours is white.
So ours is flour.
Oh yeah, it's flour, right?
Yeah.
Or ours is flour.
But in American Costco, they use corn for their...
for their tortillas so that's why they're like yellow but in
canada we use flour because i don't know i guess we just
don't have enough corn or something we just i don't know we
just don't have enough corn i don't know but for some reason
canadian costco uses white white uses flour instead it's
just look down hun yeah
just has infinite corn i mean you guys do uh you guys do
have texas right that's where the corn comes from right i
don't know i don't know agriculture i don't know where does
corn come i don't know which state grows corn i just think i
just think of oh i just think of kansas because of wizard of
oz um because she is kansas in kansas is in texas right so
like you know how dorothy is like we ain't in kansas no more
so that's why where i think corn comes from uh because
there's a lot of corn in wizard of oz there's not so i'm
like which state grows corn i'm like i don't know like
kansas like wait wait is kansas not in texas where the fuck
is kansas i i'm like making so many people angry today today
happy christmas everyone all merry christmas and happy
christmas Eve everyone um in the spirit of Christmas I'm
here to rage bait wait where the fuck is Kansas wait Kansas
is his own state I thought it was in Texas because they felt
it's so similar they they're like tornado states right
they're they're both tornado states right
yeah yeah very you are good bro I don't even know my own
country's geography let alone our neighbors um turn off the
stream ducky bird is over party
wait okay kansas all right cut up okay we're okay kansas oh
it's like right above texas it's all i was almost there i i
was thinking with a super chat thank you thank you Don't
keep rage baiting U.S.
and Mexican dragons and less than an hour away.
No.
Okay.
I can name three Canadian provinces.
Quebec is one, right?
No, Quebec is in a pro- wait.
It's Quebec a province.
They want, they want to be.
Okay.
Jesus, turkey.
Wait, is Quebec a province?
Okay, Quebec.
See, I got...
There you go.
Quebec, are you talking about Quebec City or whatever?
Okay, Quebec is one of them.
It's not looking so good.
See, I can name three provinces.
Quebec, British Columbia, and Saskatchewan.
Wait, is that tarot?
Yeah, there we go.
There we go.
I always remember Saskatchewan.
Because Saskatchewan is like the is like the Alabama of
Canada because it's all about farming.
Wait, is Alabama about farming?
I just I just Is Alabama the farm is that's where all the
farmers are too, right?
Or is that also Kansas?
Is that also Kansas?
No?
Okay, Saskatchewan is like the farming province.
That's what I remember.
Where I just remember Saskatchewan a lot.
And I don't know.
Okay, wait.
What's the farming state in America?
What the?
Oh, okay.
Saskatchewan is like the Kansas of Canada because that's
where all the farmers live I mean that's where they're like
the the farming is focused on I mean there's farmers
everywhere in Canada but like Saskatchewan is where we focus
the farming shit so I don't know Ohio or something okay okay
Saskatchewan is the Midwest of America but for Canada So
that's what Saskatchewan is.
And that's why I remember Saskatchewan.
And I remember Quebec because Quebecois.
And then I remember British Columbia because West Coast.
It's like, oh yeah, you know Canada named three provinces.
Bam, three provinces.
I don't know how many provinces are in Canada, by the way.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think we didn't rage bait enough demographic say something
about Europe.
I think it can name more European countries than I can name
That can name American states.
There's too many.
There's 50 states.
I can't name them all guys I am winter.
Thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Don't you wake up.
You're in a coma chat isn't real Saskatchewan isn't real.
Quebec isn't real.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Terminator, thank you for the super chat.
This is now geography stream instead of like gaming stream.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I wanted to say something else, but I already forgot.
Yeah, no.
What do you mean rest in peace East Coast?
Quebec is East Coast.
It's literally the other side of the country.
I literally named Mid Coast, East Coast and And West Coast,
those were the three provinces.
I'm on a watch list now.
John, in the super chat, did you think Canadian educational
education system failed this year?
No, no, no.
Because my international schools follow the American
education system.
To be fair, because I was in an international school, school
we learn we focus more on general world history than like
focused on like specific countries we just learn like world
history so so like that's why i have lots of information
gaps like i have a general knowledge of the world but not
specific things so that's why there's a huge gap of a lot of
things when it comes to when you get when it comes to like
naming specific stuff and school so like we couldn't focus
on a particular country so it was more so like let's learn
about world history and the war is and everything whoa yeah
like I learned about like the war is the like the world wars
I learned about the Cold war I learned about like the the
wars that included everyone because we have to be very
inclusive about like you know the world history so we didn't
focus on specific stuff it was something i want to talk
about but forgot what it was oh well maybe i'll come back to
me uh all right guys okay we have to finish this game we
can't we'll talk about this tomorrow What am I talking
about?
Guys, wait, was I using controller?
Mouse and keyboard.
Yeah, I felt like it's been a while since I played, so I had
to, like, remind myself.
Alright.
Mouse and keyboard time.
Guys, I have six runs to do.
Like, if I succeed in all six runs.
God, be safe.
We can learn about history tomorrow on Christmas.
I'll get that blasted Typhon for this, Freenos.
Just you watch.
All right, here we go.
I know.
How's it going on Olympus recently?
Or wherever you were last night.
See anything good up there besides the snow?
Not sure how come I know about snow.
I made it all the way to the summit where I confronted the
ancient monster called Typhon.
It said that all of the monsters can be traced directly to
him.
But he's by far the biggest and the worst I've ever seen.
Let's hope this is the next run I fucking beat him.
I hope to God, because then I'll be another plus one.
All right, let's go.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Now, well, okay, time to pick up some scraps.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
How'd that get there?
Denied.
I wonder what this is.
I've always wondered what this story goes to.
to have our aimless clashes only then to sneer at one
another here again and again such a worthy cause i got
someone's like how many successful surface runs has dokey
done that's funny don't worry about it don't worry about it
you should ask that after the stream when we beat the game
you're unbelievable guys how do we tell them Oh, frozen
life.
Ooh, hey, something new.
Oh, wait, that's good.
A place to restore HP?
That's always good.
Oh, where did...
Where did Hekatee go?
Alright, let's grab some plants real quick.
We gotta keep growing.
Gotta grow, grow, grow.
I don't know.
Grow a plantain.
I don't think we need it, but I'll just grow it just in
case.
been quite concerned i'm not lagging right confrontations
with typhon reckon you never trained to take opponents of
that size oh i trained just last night hi that's good um the
only issue about like having a 500 hertz monitor and then
also um i i have a 240 hertz on the for my second monitor
but like i put it on 60 hertz instead of you know 240
because it's apparently not good to have all your monitors
maxed out on hertz because it'll like drain your power or
some shit i don't fucking know the the tech details about it
so because of that sometimes when i look at my obs it looks
like i'm lagging but it's just the hertz difference they say
a lot of things god is why are you doing with 500 hertz
playing fps games it's it's actually really good with fps
games or aiming games
Yeah, there's no point having more Hertz on a second
monitor, but it does look like I'm lagging when I look on my
second monitor on my OBS.
It like fucks with me.
It actually does benefit a lot to have like higher Hertz
monitor for like competitive shooters.
Got yet another Titan up against us, huh?
Prometheus.
One of the smart ones, so they say.
And now, an enemy could have been on our side had your
family.
not you know oh yeah locked him up and then have an eagle
eat his kidney every day i don't know you know i thought
he'll forgive me you know yes the whole chain into a
mountain so an eagle or liver sorry it's almost the same
thing not one of the proudest moments on olympics i have to
imagine yeah but now he gains a best friend is it really
that bad if he made a friend along the way i gave him a
lifelong friendship
Watch with the treason, Nem.
Mint says a lot of things, guys.
If you follow everything Mint says,
might not be ideal for health reasons.
All right.
Let's see.
get anything right now i only have one insight also um i
mean i could buy this doesn't really matter but i can buy at
least i need more than i have to while you just join it up
commander how am i to overcome a foe whose life force is
completely undetectable typhon the bringer of storms
conceals his strength from me but it must have its limits
you know young one most of us We just hit each other till
somebody ends up dead.
Maybe there's signs like cuts and bruises and whatnot.
He's not impervious.
The gods have vanquished him before you.
Yeah, I could do it.
All right.
I am a little worried.
Okay, wait, what's my...
What's my...
Is it...
Someone said Cersei is also really good against him, but I
don't know.
Try to use Cersei or Momis.
Guys.
I think Momus has been doing very well for me, but like,
what is the most ideal, like, aspect for you guys?
For Typhon.
Oh, I should grab this.
Uh, I'll get money first.
Uh, maybe I'll, you know what?
Hmm, where is someone said, maybe...
Who was the best Cersei with cast build?
Momus is easier to use.
Momis has been like, good for me.
Easy double cast spam.
But they're both good.
Oh, I'll try Cersei's for this one.
We'll see how it goes.
Dish the damn cat.
But he's been amazing.
He's been hitting people.
And I get death defiance.
I need another death defiance.
Alright, what should we get for the first town?
The cat is good.
good.
I know.
I love the cat.
We have a Zeus cast?
Okay.
Uh, where's Zeus?
Okay, there you go.
We'll get the cloud bangle for that then.
Okay, so is this a...
Alright, there you go.
There's my cat.
Me and my cat.
Alright, here we go.
Wake up, cat.
It's time.
We're going to the surface.
No holding back.
Oh, hey!
Just when I got the Zeus Yeah, uh, let's use Memento.
Good timing.
What's that quote?
Wake up, bitch.
We're going shopping?
I remember the quote.
He's no master.
Okay, here you go.
Uh, okay.
Okay, wait, attack.
You know when girls go in the car and then they're like,
wake up, they're like, say you know like they were going to
car there's this movie the famous movie clip of this what
the fuck oh rarefied wait can i rarefied this whoa nice yeah
oh shit okay a caster what the fuck right off the bat too
okay oh whoops forgot about this this guy.
What a stench.
All right.
This tab.
Oh, the god it belongs to first room.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Oh yeah, get in.
Fellow, we're going shopping.
Yeah, that's the quote, right?
Okay, you gotta wake up though for this.
Oops, I used it too early.
Okay, I need a rummer to wake her up if I use this cast.
Trim, welcome to Tamia Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Yeah, I need a cast, Boon.
Oh, hey, okay, you're a cast.
I don't want scorched for my cast, though.
Yeah, I don't want scorched for it.
I hated that.
Maybe my special?
Oh, my special launches, but...
Yeah, I'll try to forget Zeus or I'll do try to get Zeus or
what's her?
Or Aris the city of a fear which once stood in solemn
tribute to the fear-inducing underworld king and queen Now
barely stands at all Yet it stands in my way What oh money
All right, I gotta be like I can prop What the fuck is proc?
I don't remember.
Okay, hammer.
Moon.
We'll grab Moon first.
I'll grab a moon.
I forgot I'll play this game.
Okay, where are you?
You gotta wake up.
Oh my god!
I told you to wake up!
Not!
Oh my god.
Okay, that's bad.
That's bad for me.
I messed up.
I got the sword.
distracted I told my cat to wake up.
I got very distracted
Moon lend me your light
Yeah, if he's died before we can do it again Yet I hold to
every faith you shall so I'm getting distracted All right,
your hex launches your hex makes you rash up rise up your
hex blasts Oh, they're all pretty bad.
Guys, they're all...
Yeah.
I don't know.
These are all pretty fucking shit.
I guess Eclipse would be good for endgame.
Okay, this is...
We gotta...
Wait, this is for endgame.
Alright.
We have...
At least we have endgame, yeah.
Might as well.
Nice.
We got some rooms, too, which is always nice.
There you go.
Oh my god, I need a room for the cast.
Alright, nice.
We have at bones.
Oh!
Alright, we gotta survive early game, yeah.
But it's a good, like, we get health back in the tiny rooms,
too, which is nice.
Alright, what are the other places?
Grab hammer, Zeus again, and then trap build after.
I'll use my free will for a little bit here.
Oh, there was a transform.
Oh.
Whoops.
I don't even remember what the transfer.
All right, maybe free will was a mistake.
Oh, no, not free will.
The GG free will.
How many of these do I have?
Where's my cat?
Wake up.
Cat, wake up.
Guys, I just need a warm-up.
I just need a warm-up.
Alright, what's this?
Taxier.
Ooh!
Your dash strike hits a larger area.
Oh, but that's good too.
Wait, guys, one or three?
Hi there, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Thank y'all for joining the Tomato Farm.
For those who are new to the members, we do have some free
wallpaper for the members.
So remember to look at the community post.
One or three?
They're both pretty good.
I see more ones than threes.
And we have member servers too.
We have a Minecraft member server and a Project Zomboid
server that's going on right now.
Remember to check out the community post guys.
I didn't check if there were rooms unlocked I got distracted
by shilling.
I shilled too hard.
No
Okay, Zeus Go ahead All right, wake up
All right, nice Go cat go go cat Go.
Wake up!
Okay, I'm just gonna destroy this real quick.
Oh, shit!
What?
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
I shill too close to the sun.
Ooh!
Three.
Right?
Yeah, all right, three.
Now to head back.
All right, no extra room.
Go free will.
All right.
All right, guys.
Chat fill time.
No more free will.
Where do we get?
What do we get?
We have.
We do have Apollo at the bottom.
We have Apollo and Poseidon at the bottom here.
See?
Right there.
We're at HP next.
HP Apollo.
Okay, we'll go there.
We're still missing three.
Okay, HP Apollo.
Like I said, this is my first run, so I'm warming up right
now.
Okay, I'll just open.
I'll just kill them first.
Oh my god.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, these are...
That's in my fucking thing now?
Okay.
We gotta survive the first run, though.
That's not looking ideal.
Alright, there we go.
At least we have health, though.
Oh my god, that's a lot of HP.
Thank god.
all right nice that should be everything right just want to
be sure i'm like a little paranoid get hp and then apollo me
down where's apollo there he is it is a boss fight though
okay i do not remember ever fighting this boss before oh
okay this is a little concerning Because I have never fought
this boss before.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
My cat's awake.
Oh my god, I almost fucked up that.
Again.
Okay, wait, wait.
Stay there!
Stay!
Please!
Yes!
Okay, I got it.
Alright.
Yeah, it's my first encounter.
I was like, I don't remember this guy.
I never fought him before.
Too many hunters failed to tame the massive raging boar but
I did it Swoust had lived and breathed I did it though Death
has been able to steal its mighty hooves and tusks I did
that for now yeah see I did though I think she's me The
father of all monsters truly Well you need but pay a visit
here and you'll find out Until then um we'll just have to
fend him off Alright let's see Oh, it has a chance to hit
two times.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
They're both good.
Do we want the supercast?
We want the supercast, right?
That's ideal for our build.
But then extra dose is so good.
Yeah, three is big, too.
All right, we'll go with two.
Because we do have the...
We have Cersei.
And then extra money, too.
We gotta get that.
Oh.
Oh, wait, not this.
Okay, I need to...
Alright, man, I have two more.
Alright, we have three Poseidons.
Poseidon really wants me to get him.
Okay, do we get Hestia or Poseidon, guys?
We have one left.
The pathway to the docks is sealed shut by a phantasmal
force that neither mortal nor immortal strength can budge.
Both are good casts.
I don't like the fight.
Fire cast.
I am not a fan of the scorch cast.
I will say that.
Just because, like, um, only because it blends in with the
attacks way too.
Like, if it blends in with the enemy stuff, yeah.
It fucks me up with it.
Because enemy stuff are, like, red, too.
Gamba?
Alright.
Well, Gamba would the one next to him.
Alright, we'll get Poseidon then.
Like I said, I don't like Hestia's cast.
It's like fucking annoying.
I wanted it to try the holding cast.
Normally I don't hold, but I wanted to try it.
Alright, get him!
Oh my god, the birds are here.
Okay, I have no mana now.
Alright.
Nice.
Easy.
gotta make sure i don't i don't get lose too much hp all
right beside it oh my god i forgot about this too oh yeah i
know i got my shit kicked in bro he was so big he literally
destroyed his own health by like what the fuck he literally
fourth walled
oh oh wait two or three we don't have a gamba but but we do
have buried treasure or we get plus a hundred percent damage
good for long term okay good long term then oh my god and we
get food too which is good Okay, no extra bonus rooms.
All right, off to fight the Cyclops.
I am so warming up.
I feel very rusty right now.
All right, drink the magic fountain.
And then we'll go to the shop.
Back to nature.
There's something to procure.
Oh, hey, fishing.
I do feel very like, very safe.
slow right now with my reaction time uh oh hey i've run into
lord hermes at the summit of olympus making preparations
against typhon with the rest have you been able to cross
paths with him good talk charon good talk i always love
talking to you oh my god it's her again oh fuck it
don't want you paying an exorbitant amount not that there
ought to be a price on blessings anyhow all right what do we
get oh okay like more oh wait that's good wait the cat like
holding cast yeah i can aim it now right three is best yeah
okay three here's the gold uh i was Actually, 20% chat.
Ah, okay, chat, which one?
One, one, or three?
Double strike or heaven strike?
Three?
20% chance?
Or blitz?
I see more ones.
One, one, three, three.
Gamba.
Three is for the future build?
Okay, we'll do three then.
Feeling fine.
We'll aim for the...
We're investing, guys.
This is long-term, guys.
We're investing for our future.
You said nobody took your eye before, as well as your sheep.
How did you lose...
Nobody played a dirty...
Guys, it's a long-term game.
Foster sailors thought they could get away with my sheep.
So I had to come.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Okay, there's sellers.
Okay, so they don't matter, yeah.
And you've sought vengeance on this nobody ever since.
Don't on me personally.
Someday somebody's gonna get nobody for what he did.
So I am gonna get you.
Yeah, but who's nobody?
Is nobody everyone?
Bro, I'm just...
I'm just chilling.
Oh, shit.
Okay, that like fucked with me though that oh my god the
fucking cast fucked with me because it's the same It's not I
know it's not the same color, but like I got so confused Oh
my god it happened again Oh my god Guys, I'm not warmed up.
I don't know if it's obvious Not warmed up at all.
Oh my god This is so bad!
I am not okay!
I...
Actually not okay, guys.
Oh my god, this is so bad.
I've never had such a terrible run before.
I lost...
I had, by the way, guys, I had a lot of HP.
I...
I originally had a lot of HP.
lot of HP guys it was crazy it was a lot I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna chill a little here I don't trust myself at all
right now
Oh Okay, um so I Okay, okay guys, I'm gonna lock in now.
I Swear to gotta lock in now.
I'm It's a bit uh guys i i'm gonna lock in now guys i i
swear i'll lock in this is where it happens where it starts
i just i my brain was my heart wasn't in it but now it is
my heart just wasn't in it now now now it is though now it
is
My heart's now in!
Guys, I swear.
I swear.
I learned from my mistakes.
Okay, I gotta get rid of him.
Yeah.
Alright, it's okay.
We're okay for now.
See, look at that.
Okay, oh my god, what?
It didn't show up on my screen!
Okay, that was cheating.
I literally didn't see that on my screen when he dived in.
Okay, it's okay.
Look at that.
Look, transform.
There you go.
Easy.
Alright, now...
Now we do.
We should get the cast.
Yeah, 60% cast.
That's good.
See, my heart's in it now, guys.
Now it's in it.
It's in it now.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Like I said, guys, guys.
I'm still warming up.
It's just a warm-up, guys.
It really is just a warm-up.
Wake up!
Oh my god.
Like, what am I even hitting?
Okay.
Okay, he's gotta wake up, though.
Alright, that's good.
There you go.
Where am I?
Oh, there.
I lost you.
track oh god not the tool are you fucking oh my god I hit
everything wake up okay it's fine oh my god wake up there
you go
okay where's my cat oh my god guys it's over it's over my
will just I it's over it's so over it's so it's very much
over I've I'm not locked in my heart's just not in it I'm
sorry my my heart's not in it
okay it's okay that thousand is gonna clutch it there we go
Here we go.
This is not the run.
It really isn't.
Okay, so I lost both my death defiances now.
Might have lost.
Okay, Gab.
All right.
Oh, nice.
Okay, guys.
This might not be the run anymore.
vortex from which not even the sleekest ship can possibly
escape all right okay i locked in now starting now starting
now i locked in
okay okay maybe the cat is not good for this build okay i
think it's also because i have a cast build and the cat's
not doing it for me right now
No, I 100%.
I might lose to Aeris.
I...
Guys, I don't even think I'm making it to her.
There's a chance I don't even make it.
Oh my god.
Guys, it's not looking so good right now.
Okay.
There we go.
I don't have a death defiance anymore.
Oh my god, I'm getting like the best shit ever, but I'm just
not locked in.
No!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm stuck in the corner.
I'm stuck in the corner.
Oh my god, I went into the fire accident.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Okay, look, I made it here though.
I lived.
I don't have a lot of HP, but I lived.
Typhon, I mean, of course.
After I wondered about his deep connection to the natural
world.
Uh, Scott, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Merry Christmas from Australia.
Here's a small gift as a thanks for entertainment.
You brought this here.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
He's a monster, just as you said.
Guys, this is just a throwaway round.
I'll be warmed up by the next run, guys.
A lock-in.
Veritably not you or I, Pop-it.
All that is here belongs is what I say.
Surely, surely.
Okay, we should get this one.
I don't know.
Actually, no, we sort of lost all our depth defiances.
Okay, maybe we can save it.
We can save it, guys.
We might be able to save this run.
Tula, go for it.
Come on out.
Here we go.
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe we can salvage the run here.
it's it's possible guys it's salvageable
okay just wake up literally that's all i need
okay we'll grab we'll grab hermes
don't worry he'll wake up guys he's gonna wake up guys oh my
god I wish my cat can like wake up himself and I don't have
to wake him up That's all I need Oh thank god
Okay It's 5 Wake up please Wake up Stop sleeping please Holy
shit After so many people everywhere Okay
Please wake up.
Nice.
Where is he?
I saw huge plumes of fire shooting from the summit of
Olympus recently.
Thought the whole mountain was erupting.
But on the closer inspection, it was you.
Fighting someone.
Oh, it's me!
Some deranged eagle chased me off.
That was Prometheus the Titan and his pet.
He's turned against the gods and is personally leading the
siege.
of olympus i don't know why he's so mad at us you know
what's about forgiveness he got he made great memories with
the bird broken free what do mortals have to do with this
whole feud with chronos anyhow i thought all he wanted was
his vengeance probably from metheus as well all right are
you Prime my special food your attack food.
Oh Oh twenty two.
No, I'm already fucked right now Maybe attack food.
Yeah, I'll go with two guys.
I'll just go.
I don't know.
We're making it far I'm just gonna free.
You know what?
I'm gonna free will this They showed up near our mountain
causing trouble again all because of you they don't know I
practically beg you to come up to our rescue over here Think
heck gave you the order.
We're really in it now All right, oh I know
I should get nitro boost.
I'm going to get three.
I think I need it.
I believe in the dodge.
I don't believe, though.
I...
Oh, move speed.
Oh, wait.
Let's do it.
I believe, actually.
Two for the gamma.
Yeah, I started believing.
Because I was like, oh, move speed is pretty.
good though wait what someone there was like the the i
thought there was a farming thing here i guess i was wrong
all right let's get hestia i swear there's there's been a
very lack of shops right now
oh my god i swear is it me or did the enemies get harder a
lot harder Okay.
I feel like the enemy's got a lot crazier.
Oh!
All right.
In the name of Hades.
All right, let's see.
The more I have, I have three.
Okay.
That's good.
I have three.
Oh my gosh, you've done scorched damage.
Oh my gosh, you've done scorched on cast.
No, but I'm already fucking up there right now.
I'm already fucking up.
I shouldn't risk it.
I'm not feeling...
Oh, and I don't get HP.
Okay, that's fine.
Rehold the stars.
Ooh.
Ooh, I like that.
I want a mini-shit.
Oh!
Alright.
I'm gonna do cast.
I'm gonna get Poseidon my cast.
Alright, here we go.
Let's lose the air.
No, I...
Yeah, no, I think I'm gonna lose here.
I have zero death defiance, this guy's.
And I'll give you something else for what you did to me last
time.
Oh, my God.
My first loss here.
I just wasn't locked in.
I didn't lock in.
Consequences?
Come on, don't be so gullible.
Anyway, I'm going to open fire now.
Guys, I'm not playing better.
Hang on, reloading.
Oh my god.
I'm not playing better.
Where is she?
I'm getting so disoriented
Oh my god Yeah, but I also had that too.
Oh my god.
Okay, it's fine Okay, it was not fine Okay, this run I'm
locked in now.
I'm locked in okay.
We're getting the frog.
You're right the cow was not in with the with Cersei The cat
was nodded with Circe, you guys.
It was not okay.
I'm not in a bad way necessarily, and I don't know how I can
smell.
Six four runs.
That is weird.
Okay, a lot of times I was lying, but this time I was
coping, but this time is real.
I'm super warmed up.
I sailed across the waters toward Olympus on a ship.
Exciting.
I was right here the whole time.
Alright, let's grab this real quick.
Alright, let's talk to all these people.
Eris upright attacked me.
Just as I was approaching Mount Olympus.
Who gave her the adamant rail anyway?
A weapon once used to slay titans turned against the gods.
The rail has turned against the gods before.
Only the fates know its true and final purpose.
But Eris has it by their own decree.
Perhaps it's a plaything to keep her occupied.
to keep me occupied apparently makes me wonder if the fates
weren't chronos stopped or not did you and eras ever fight
like this the thing is the cat's really good oh my god i'm
not talking to her i refuse to talk to her after i lost to
her i
i didn't even see what i upgraded what the fuck did i get I
refuse to give her what she wants.
If I never talked to her, technically I never lost to her.
She can't glow.
I'm not giving her what she wants.
What did I get?
I was so mad.
I didn't even check my upgrades.
Wait, I need P2.
Give me a sec.
I am back.
What did I get?
I actually don't know.
You guys need help.
I made something that I don't know what I made.
oh boy mary thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
i don't think you was super chat thank you thank you papa
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you guys what
did i make
greater gifts of gala okay here you go oh okay each
gathering tool okay enhances the gathering tool Sister
Selene notified me.
It was Eris herself who barred you from gaining the heights
of- Okay, okay, I did not talk to you to fucking get shamed,
okay?
I- I'm not talking to anyone.
If everyone here is gonna shame me, I shall now not interact
with anyone here.
If you're all gonna be here to shame me, I might as well
just do another run.
What say the ashes?
Why do I need shadow?
How do I get shadow?
Chief, it's real.
Oh my god, okay.
Now she fucking takes over the cauldron.
Wait, I'll try.
I'll try Cersei one more time, but I think I might need to
get the frog.
I think the frog might have to be it.
Alright, and then we'll grab this for Zeus.
What was this?
Oh, this is the upgrades for the...
Might as well upgrade it.
home requisition authorized yeah now grab this too yes
blackfire thank you for the 20 gift of ships thank you thank
you shame shame i refuse to be shamed all right we go in all
right we got the fraud this time this time we'll do what oh
wait no i got this news i got
All right, we'll try this again.
You've seen it now, first hand.
Our great mountain is perpetually besieged.
And we've not had a moment's peace of late.
Yet this trial only makes us stronger as that.
If I fuck up Cersei again, I'm going back to Momus.
Okay, but this time I'm locking in.
Oh, hey, there we go.
Okay, we got the cast for it, too.
That's what we wanted.
We got the Thunderbolt cast, too.
Yeah.
Oh no, now I have to fish for myself.
Oh, yeah!
I forgot to rarefight.
It's okay.
Maybe I'll have the strong cast, you know?
All right.
We did it, Frenos.
What would Demeter be good for?
If Kronos truly is behind the reawakening of Typhon, Then he
is not merely arrogant, but mad.
He promises another golden age, yet visits such a creature
on this world.
I know, right?
Can't believe it.
He would mix...
Oh, wait.
He would mix gods and creatures.
One special, or...
Or attack.
One or two, chat.
Two?
Two.
I will grab two.
Alright, let's go in.
Alright, here we go.
Back at it again.
Uh, oh wait, we'll talk to her first.
We don't have a moon.
Oh wait, we do have...
We have magic and Zeus.
Do we want to do another Zeus?
Okay, talk first.
Yeah, talk is the easiest.
Have I gifted her yet, guys?
I don't remember.
Oh, I don't have gifts anyway, so never mind.
doing everywhere lady media they control the barrier before
the docks that much is clear perhaps the titans legions use
them to coordinate attacks they are the product of a very
sick mind imprisoning so many shades in the tiniest
enclosures wherein all their psyche may be drained can you
imagine sorceress that's terrible i hadn't realized the
pylons worked that way though who keeps fixing them yeah
yeah wait that's true hideous thing won't seem to go away oh
it comes up by itself i was gonna be like media are you all
playing for the wrong are you playing both sides girl all
right but after four joins around takes one oh my god we
should gamble
wait is it one guy or like any foe that joins that
or is it one of them or like all of them chat just one or do
all of them get gambed all foes is gamba time we're gambling
okay that's actually pretty that's a good gamba oh yeah i
don't have any salute i don't have any gifts over here i'm
broke sorry girl some sort of gathering oh hey money You
mean some sort of money?
Oh, is that nice?
I'll gather it around to give me money.
Oh, okay, we should get... I'll get the moon.
I don't want to grab this first.
Yeah, death to Kronos!
Oh shit!
Wait, money.
Okay, nice.
I didn't remember to freeze that.
Oh my god, how the fuck is there fire in front of me?
Oh wait, mining.
Mining, mining.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna definitely get the second Zeus later.
I regret our meetings are in haste and that we are unable to
converse when thus we meet.
I am expected high aloft for all to see.
Our connection is to remain as hidden as the crossroads.
We are to move in shadows.
Aw.
Now.
Okay, Night Bloom.
Okay, Night Bloom's the best one.
Yeah, Night Bloom's the best one.
I'm gonna get Night Bloom.
All right, nice.
Freeze.
That's right, freeze!
Oh, wait, that was fast.
Okay, go back.
Leave, and then we get...
Where's the hammer?
Hammer is next to me.
I'm going to get hammer first.
Gamba time!
Gamba!
Wait, why are you not Gamba?
Where's my Gamba?
Excuse me, but why is he very alive?
I swear to God, I saw zero damage.
Wait, did he got Gamba?
Oh my God, this is so strong.
Oh, those who joined.
Oh, I thought it shows up, like, I thought it was for
everyone.
I don't feel like I don't use Taz that much, but I don't
know.
As the Junking.
One, two, or three.
Okay, I thought, like...
Okay, we should...
I mean, I've been...
using range a lot now all right two okay all right more
range oh hey nice oh my god I keep thinking I have the okay
it's fine you're not transformed that's why fight your
friend yeah all money that's right you were best friends now
you kill each other as it should As it'd be...
Alright, nothing here.
And then we go to Zeus.
I think Zeus was like, down here?
I'm pretty sure.
What the fuck?
Where did this come from?
Who built a house here?
Yeah, who the fuck built a house here?
I'm so... Oh my god, that's fire!
Fire bad!
enemies shall scatter to the four winds once we're through
with them our challenges to purge them while minimizing
unspeakable devastation and lady Demeter could always make
the earth regrow okay let's see oh duo we grow where not a
trace of life remains that's of little consequence right now
let all who oppose us wither yeah I actually really needed a
duo I'm not doing so well right now.
Oh, yeah, nice.
Okay, definitely two then.
Bellstorm.
I think I'm finished here.
Okay, wait, is there an extra room?
No.
Goodbye.
That's good.
I'll have to use freeze more, though.
Oh, my God, I have to freeze more.
Okay, I have two more left.
Where are the bats?
Bats!
What's left of Aphira?
guys i feel like i should get hp right should i get hp or hp
and hermes or should i do like more of the booms or the
palms yeah okay hp and hermes i swear the runs got a lot
harder i think like the enemies got harder not these ones
but i mean like they have these now too I only think it's
harder because I haven't seen those flags before until like
today from all my runs
Oh nice, okay, nice Okay, oh my god, there's a house About
to destroy the house Um, the HOA did not authorize this
building Okay
Oh, I just need to be able to aim My cast now
Oh, hey, Ness.
Oh, my God.
Double lightning, too.
Oh, they died so fast.
Oh, nice.
More magic.
Oh, hey.
Oh, I thought he was, like, one of those people that would
join my crew.
I feel like I haven't seen the flags in, like, the surface
world before.
Like, I saw it in Kronos, but, like, today was the first
time I've seen it here.
Oh, my God.
built this house again we did not prove your building
jesus christ
all right because you lightning me you get death
nice are you missing oh there yeah goodness oh my god i
didn't see the fire i think it's like the psych okay now i
know why i keep missing the fires because of the psychic
link fucks with me.
Because that's also red and it fucks with me so much.
I made it back from work.
What did I miss?
This is my first run.
You didn't miss anything, X Factor.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good for you.
You came back for my first run.
Alright.
Oh, attack special end caster faster.
No more damage.
the next 45.
Which one?
First run.
First run, everyone.
Yeah, I just finished chatting.
I had a very long chatting session.
That's why we're still here.
All right, one.
Thank God.
Yeah, I made sure to wait for you, Factor.
Oh, God.
oh i can afford all of this you've sailed far from your
usual course boatman not solely on my account i trust wow
good talk good talk i always love talking to you generous
aid is much appreciated lord okay
whoa wait one or three
all right chat one or three one is okay I see more ones
Alright, one So I was at three for Cersei But we'll do one
Last time I built for long term It didn't work I'm here for
short term Short term investments now Short term payout I
want it now I don't want to wait 20 years Don't even try and
sneak by What you think It might if you keep Blocking my
path, you'll get another thrashing and you'll be sound
asleep again in no time.
That what you want?
Oh Got a dilemma on my hands I'm always sleepy But I'm
always hungry too.
All right, here you go Boom Okay, I've learned my lesson.
Don't worry.
I have long-range cast now.
So I learned my lesson All right
Don't worry.
I've learned my lesson
I learned
What?
Okay, I pressed dash there
First guy
Oh my god, okay, I hope that hits him Oh shit Oh my god, I
almost like hit myself too I swear these are new Have I not
been paying attention?
Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god, please, my minion.
Anytime now.
All right, here we go.
That will show him.
Yeah, we did it.
Okay, see, we're doing better now, guys.
See, I'm locking it in little by little, chat.
Look at that.
I did it.
I didn't lose the depth of finds this time.
Slowly but surely.
The conditions under which they graze about and wander.
Not exactly lost.
At least not yet.
The one they have to guide them.
That is, but yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm getting better from last stream's runs, guys.
That's what I mean, obviously.
Yeah.
I still have the rarefied thing.
Oh, I forgot to use the rarefied.
All right, up we go.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, that's fine.
I just didn't know where he came from.
I might as well get magic.
Okay, buddy.
All right, it's fine.
It's okay.
I still live.
Oh.
What is it?
Oh, some cannon buzz.
Yoink.
Bye, cannon buzz.
Everything's okay.
Everything is okay.
Oh, okay.
Shit, Gambo worked out!
Yeah!
Let's go!
The Gambo worked out.
There you go.
Yeah.
Holy fuck, I did not expect him to run at me there.
Oh my god.
I got a little worried.
Nice.
Oh, it didn't matter.
Moon or Hermes, chat.
Which is better?
Moon or Hermes?
Oh, goodbye.
I see more Hermes than Moon.
Okay, I'll do Hermes then.
I saw more Hermes, so I'm gonna go for that then.
I'll make it closer.
It'll be a shame if, you know, something happens to me.
I'm not leaving this area, that's for sure.
There you go.
There's literally a fire pit there.
I'm not crossing that bridge.
Oh.
And your cast expires.
Okay, I feel like we need our cast more, though.
I guess quick bug?
Yeah.
Oh, hey.
Are you really...
Are you fucking kidding me?
You do it for this guy?
Okay, that's fine.
That's okay.
Echo.
I didn't want you to do it for this.
Oh, no.
I'm so bad for these.
I'm actually so bad against the snow.
Oh, wait.
Unless I'll just freeze him, I guess.
Oh, shit.
It doesn't matter.
I forgot he fucking turns.
Oh, my God.
I hate.
I actually hate this boss a lot.
Like, he fucks with me a lot.
Because of the thing turning.
It, like, messes me up.
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, really?
Yeah, I froze him, though.
Okay, that's fine.
Whoa!
That's fine.
He's almost...
Okay, okay, nice.
I broke him.
Break time!
Break!
The sea claims another.
go see all those chronos ships trudging this way would you
most of them already sunk before over many times they and
their dead crews keep coming back to want us now that's some
yeah i don't oh it's because we they took he took over hell
it's like how come the dead keeps coming back because
there's no hell right now summing it up if it was near after
you dash okay guys when you're and oh i don't know they're
all pretty not gonna lie i i do hate all of them i will say
shield i will grab shield very well not really a fan of any
of them oh what's this what's the rule come catch me if you
can oh i oh okay this is not good for me Oh!
Let's hope I can do it!
Oh!
Okay, that's good.
I'll grab this guy over here.
Okay, I froze him.
That's good.
Okay, I froze him and tapped.
Nice.
Oh, thank God I actually needed that.
Yay!
Nice.
Oh!
It's fine.
Everything is safe.
I feel so safe.
Oops.
I messed that up a little bit.
I actually have a minion now.
Oh my god, he's actually helpful.
Oh, and more hearts.
I mean, health is health.
I'll take it.
health okay that's fine oh my god frozen just in time too
that's so scary
okay nice okay more health yeah more health health is wealth
oh we got this oh my life nearby where do i have five oh
there he is Freenos, do your thing.
All right, join my army.
See you in the crossroads.
How shameful that we now resort to common subterfuge.
Having our correspondence smuggled to and fro by the
erstwhile boatmen of the dead.
All right.
Oh.
Mm-mm.
Oh, okay.
Maybe it also creates a gust.
That should be good.
Yeah.
Three?
Where am I cast?
Yeah, okay.
I was thinking, since mine is a cast build.
Okay.
We're almost there.
Oh, God.
I always have to, like, be aware of the fucking these guys
dashing in randomly.
It's so random whenever it happens.
Oh, my God.
Like, right now, I didn't expect them there.
It's okay.
He's burning himself.
Why are you burning yourself?
Uh...
Grab ash.
Ash is always good.
Jesus Christ, I can't see anything.
I hope everything is okay, because I don't know what the
fuck is going on.
A gift.
Yay!
Oh, another shot.
Let's go!
I did transform.
You just couldn't see him because the because everything is
so fucking hard to see
okay we can grab zeus again the name of haiti's
oh you mean you mean the plot i thought my transform i
thought you guys were talking about my moon power i thought
you were talking about my i was like what are you guys
talking about look see my minions here i that's why i
thought i didn't I forgot that you can transform Ash into
power-ups.
Okay, I remember now, guys.
See, I'm warming up.
This is only my first run, chat.
This is only my first run, guys.
I'm warming up.
Okay, which one?
One, two, or three?
Because we fight Eros here.
Yeah, first run.
Yeah.
Three?
Okay, let's do three.
I'm gonna grab Moon, too.
Manifest your desire.
Why is there another Zeus?
I didn't realize another Zeus showed up!
Okay, it's fine.
I needed to use...
I forgot the Herbie's Bomb.
It's okay.
It's fine.
We needed this.
We needed this, guys.
Why do I have to pay for....
Okay good, I forgot what the Hermes purchased shit.
It's okay.
We needed this, guys.
We needed this.
Oh, wait, that's good.
All right, we'll do that.
And then we might as well just buy...
Oh, we'll save up, actually.
I'm going to save up.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
I just didn't...
I didn't want to buy another Zeus, guys.
I didn't, guys.
It's okay.
It's just a warm-up.
It's just a warm-up, guys.
I want to save my...
Fuck it.
I feel like we don't have nectar a lot.
It's fine.
We don't need to save.
myself
real clear with you before but here you are like nothing
happened and it's just another night this is just another
night to me eris it's okay i figured it out guys i figured
it out you're just another obstacle on my path hate to break
it to you trouble obstacles are things you're supposed to
avoid but in this channel you're going to run into me every
time oh my god i wish i could like edit game files i wish
there's a mod where i could just delete her from the game
like i should be legally allowed to just delete her from
this game like i don't care replace her with another like
just replace her with another fucking character
this is the only reason why i got him too
All right, there you go Oh fuck, okay, okay, I thought like
I can just like chill here
It's bad, I have this, I have long range What the?
What?
She like pushed me into the fire There we go Okay, that's
cheating
Actually cheating.
But can I be here?
Oh my god, okay, I'll be here.
That's fine.
Okay, I have this.
Oh my god, no, not the fight.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, it's fine.
Where did she go?
Get frogged!
Oh, a fucking course you leave.
Fucking coward.
Oh my god, thank god.
Alright, I'll leave.
A hundred percent damage?
Oh my god.
Okay, I didn't see her.
Where are you fucking joking?
There she is.
That's it.
Oh.
need another friend I got froggy it's okay I don't need a
friend I got froggy here that's all the friends I need to
feel again the stable earth beneath her feet replenishes
within the princess okay we figured it out guys nearly
limitless resolve as her objective finally draws near that's
right it's like it's crazy like I beat her like 20 plus
times she beats me once and then It's like the one time she
feeds me.
He's like, yeah, I'm beat you.
I'm like, yeah, you're lost to me 20 plus times.
Oh, wow, the 21st time you win.
Oh, wow.
Guys, I don't know which one to use.
I guess I do this and then I do knuckle, I'm gonna do deft
of fives.
I don't trust.
Actually, I'll do knuckle bones and then deft of fives on
the last one.
I think that's the only way.
Yeah, I fell for the rage, babe.
I did.
Got me.
I thought you guys were mortal enemies.
What happened?
Wait.
Oh my god, what the fuck is going on?
Okay, there you go.
Like, why are you guys...
Why are you guys fighting me?
I thought y'all were mortal enemies.
We'll grab one and it means the lovers.
Okay, there's my friend here.
All right, we'll get the hammer.
Hammer's always important.
All right, here we go.
Come on, here we go.
Nice.
Okay, nice.
I got the friend now.
Okay, there should be more summons.
Oh, fuck.
I forgot about this guy.
The shooter.
There you go.
That's a hive.
It's not cowardly.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's cast.
Wait.
Plus.
Ooh, a two or a three?
Chat.
Two?
All right.
A sturdy star.
Make sure you do that.
All right.
This is...
Palm.
I'll get the upgrade.
Yeah.
Oh my god!
Oh fuck!
Okay, it's okay.
I got a little scared there.
I did not see him.
I'm just gonna stay back here.
It's okay.
I'll just spam this.
I just spam this.
Okay.
you oh god not these guys these guys i worry for goodness oh
shit what she did like a teleport behind me i was not
expecting it he actually tp behind me all right oh just okay
which one one two or three i guess storm ring i guess
Or one.
Nothing personal, kid.
Two?
Yeah, I already have.
No, these are upgrades.
These are upgrades.
Because...
Two?
Okay, I'll do two.
I'll do the lightning.
I knew there was money here.
I fucking knew it.
You can't hide the gold from me.
Through heals.
Okay.
oh shit okay for some reason in my head i was waiting for
the dive i was like when will i start i thought i was gonna
skydive into it that was my bad i whoops i was just waiting
for myself to skydive jokes out of me i just tanked it
oh chair oh i don't know if it's It's worth it.
Okay, I don't know if it's worth to get chaos.
Guys, do you think it's worth to get chaos, chat?
I don't know.
It's a gambo time.
It is?
Okay.
Gambo time.
Gamba time.
Oh, hey.
Mining.
Oh.
It's a bit risky, yeah.
That's why I'm scared.
of the course and outcome of all lives all preordained
that's the sense of oh nice oh no it's normal game soon i
think the fate's determined much about our lives when and
where we are born for instance and to whom but i don't think
they set every detail and i know they're not leaving at all
right now because chronos has them all right for the most
part i concur with your assessment I am the reason Kronos
has them now.
You asked me where to find them, and I decided to tell them.
To verify such choices could be made without their
influence.
Now do you understand my quandary?
Respond.
Please respond.
Oh, no.
Almighty Chaos, you were deceived.
Kronos wished to find the fates for his own gain.
They were one of the only forces in this world powerful
enough to stop him.
They are not so powerful as they appeared.
Nevertheless, I think you are correct.
Foros indicated his intentions were benign.
I am unfamiliar.
No!
Chaos, how could you get baited so easily?
Team Journey, Forest Health.
Oh, that's so bad for late game.
Three encounters.
Guys, I don't know if I could do that.
three encounters in 120 seconds guys that is way too hard
yeah yeah
i'm gonna do two i don't okay no dashes i mean it takes away
my h my magic so it's not like that bad yeah not in this
world i don't trust myself in this world oh hey by the toil
on the otherwise besieged olympus heights three years little
breath remains to her for now can't rest here not for long i
mean can't dash out i feel so oh wait actually oh hey
transform transform god fucking okay that's okay wait
where's the oh we start all right i need to pee again i i
hydrated way too much help me figure out which to get
all right uh many saw it adam thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you all right which is best guys which one
should i get let me double check something real quick right
which one they're both good okay you guys didn't agree on
anything He's like, so we agree then?
Yeah, both of the guys, I mean, it's one or the other.
It's one or the other.
It's not...
Okay, we're going for half.
I'm going for half, guys.
Yeah, both is probably the smart choice.
Okay.
I'm just gonna make sure I don't die to that.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I got that fire!
Okay, that's an accident.
I got a little bit.
Alright.
I hate the fire.
I hate the fire so much.
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
Let's buy it.
There you go.
Okay, it's okay.
It is not okay.
Please, Froggy!
Oh, God.
Nice.
Oh!
Barry, thank you, Mr. Super Chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
Yesterday was my birthday, and it'll be great.
Oh, she would sing.
Happy birthday for me.
Of course, Barry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Barry.
Yeah!
Happy birthday.
Wait.
Whenever you take damage, shrug some of it off.
Oh my god.
Okay.
One.
Should I get one?
For the dash?
Or a dash?
three and then my dash okay i'll grab dash oh hey morning
morning all right palm time oh it's okay we'll just wait let
them fight it's okay and then i'll come in and take the
rewards oh okay whoops
Okay, that is a lot of fucking spears thrown at me.
It's fine.
We'll be here.
Me and Froggy will be here in the corner.
In the safe corner.
Alright, here we go.
Your specialty is your cast.
Cost learning.
Alright, one, two, or three, chat.
Yeah, I kill sealed at the end.
Like a real gamer.
One?
Alright.
What's this?
Burn?
Wait.
Slayer foe?
Oh, okay.
Oh.
That's easy.
It's okay.
I have this.
It's fine.
Oh, wait.
It's just here.
Yay!
Easy.
Monument cleansed.
We got free moon.
We gotta get all the way to here.
Wait, actually.
Okay, we're gonna get over here.
One, two, three.
We're getting to that other side.
Uh.
Alright, chat.
Palm or Poseidon?
Yeah, the summon carry there.
Poseidon?
Alright, Poseidon time.
I'll grab some flowers while they fight.
What?
Okay, I did not see the gust.
Oh my god.
It's always like something screen clutter.
I think that's like my only biggest gripe is that sometimes
there's just... The screen clutter is just too much
sometimes.
I'm just so bad with it.
Hit us, but...
Oh my god, I can't...
I keep forgetting to not dash.
He's messing me up.
He's like, Toki, stop dashing!
Buzz feels so nice!
If dashing is bad, why does it feel so good?
The boon from Chaos just took hold.
Nice.
Olympus, I accept this message.
Uh, his surrounding foes as a Star Trek, but you prime 30.
Yeah, I could dash now!
Puba after.
Really, really sore.
One or three?
Blood gain?
Alright, we'll do one.
The ocean's fury.
Alright, uh, wait, what?
room am i in am i 43 i'll get another shop right 50 is the
end right chat is 50 the end because i have i do have a lot
of money is it better for jera shop though okay i'll go shop
i was thinking if i should get more health or not because i
couldn't i don't know did hermes leave me this oh hey nice
Uh, I make it by everything, technically.
Alright.
Ooh!
Whoa!
I always use magic.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Hold cast aim.
Oh, but I can aim my cast.
Oh, fuck.
They're all good.
Wait, they're all really good, chat.
Which is better for long term.
One or two.
Two?
Two, okay.
Okay, I can get another one.
Oh my god, it's the meter.
Okay.
Oh, that's just late in the game.
That sucks.
Yeah.
Three.
Oh, everyone's conflicted.
I've been hoping.
hold Q.
I don't hold it as often.
Also don't...
Oh my god, he's like knocking my, trying to knock my door
down.
Wait, I didn't even... Okay, give me a sec.
Let's check what he wants.
Sorry, I'm back.
He wanted...
Did you guys agree on something?
Did the hive... Oh yeah, by the way, I watched Pluribus.
I watched the first two episodes of Pluribus.
Why can't you guys be like them?
The hive mind.
all i'm all i'm saying guys why can't you guys have a have
my like these those people in florida their council agreed
on two it's a good show i like it so far i hate them in
character but it's a good show oh he just wanted attention
he was like give me food he literally baited me outside and
like looked at the kitchen and was like looking the the
treat bones and i'm like no you had you had like one you
only have one a day because she's like supposed to be a
karen and like the whole she has like anger issues so
pleuribus is basically like what if the world became a hive
mind so everyone keeps talking about the show because it's
from the creators of breaking bad and better call salt and
it's literally filmed around the same location too and the
whole premise is like what if the world became a hive mind
like got infected by a virus that made everyone join their
minds together and became a hive mind not everyone survives
the integration into it because it's like a virus um and
obviously it has to do with your fucking mind and then so
and there's only like 13 people who are immune to the virus
and um everyone keeps talking about it on my twitter feed
because they're like oh it's created by the the it's created
by the people created Breaking Bad so I checked so the the
main character she has anger problems and i assume that like
whenever she gets angry at the hive mind like the people in
the hive mind they start having seizures and like people
start dying because like i like this is my theory and i
think it's because like um the people just don't like it
when like you know because it's a hive mind it's everyone's
thoughts and everyone's thoughts are integrated together so
like obviously like some of the people might not like
getting mad at you know like might not like people getting
angry at them for us and then they like freak out and
something that's why they're in seizure because like
everyone's like fighting each other in the hive mind being
like i don't like it when someone's mad at me it makes me
really depressed like or like it makes me really bad too and
then the hive mind inside has like their own inner conflict
because of that so where every time the main character gets
angry at them millions of people die so um so like but then
she keeps doing it yeah she's like oh my And then she like,
when she first did it, she threw it out, throws it out.
Because she's like, oh my God, I just killed 11 million
people.
But then she knows, she knows every time she gets angry,
people die.
But she keeps doing it.
Like, I watched two episodes and she did it three fucking
times in two episodes.
And I'm like, stop getting angry at them.
You know, you feel shit when people die.
Like, I'm like, bro, you always feel fucking shit when it
happens.
but yet you still get rage baited like yeah because everyone
around the world is doing something like maybe they're
driving a car like on a plane but then they get into a
fucking seizure for like a couple like for like a minute or
something and then like literally like she come she like
triggers a seizure and then like less than like a couple of
hours later she gets angry again but she's like I can't
believe I'm so sad I killed a lot of people and then she
gets rage baited again and it's like a cycle so i it's like
a fucking cycle anyway what are we getting guys one two or
three are we doing the lightning bolts two i heard it does
get like the show does not does get worse as the episode
goes on because like the first episode's the best episode
and then like after that these people are saying like it's
not as good as oh my god it's eagle time um it it doesn't
get better which sucks because like i i it was pretty i
thought it was really interesting so far it's memory game
time because the premise is super interesting despite the
plunders that you made it now it's been great so far i guess
it's like it's a slow burn people are saying like it's a
very slow burn i realize this must be complicated for you as
someone whose loyalties are mostly to an eagle but i am not
about to let that thing destroy everything my family i like
the story i like the story i just don't like the main
character i mean it's also like another thing about the
thing is that the rest of the survivors are like taking
advantage of it be like what if it's like i want to fly to
this country with the uh with the uh the president's plane
and shit like that I want eight women to accompany me.
Like, you know, they're taking advantage of like, ah, no,
it's cool.
You know, I get to do anything I want.
Because the hive mind will always will cater to the immune
people.
So literally it's like you have, you can do whatever the
fuck you want.
So they're like, so Carol, the main character, is like the
only one that feels like, am I the only one that just wants
to fix the world and like make everyone back to normal
again?
And the other survivors are like, yeah.
Like, we like it like this.
Like, so like, He's like, I'm fucking going crazy.
I'm the only one that wants to fucking save the human race.
Yeah.
So sex with everyone's mind connected.
That's true.
Yeah.
So the problem was that one of the immune people was like,
um, this is my son.
Like her, the son got connected to the hive mind.
And she's like, yeah, but like, I have everything I want.
See, I still have my son.
And then Carol, the main character was like, that's not your
son.
Not just your son.
That's your ex-boyfriend.
That's your chiropractor.
That's your gynecologist.
That's everybody in your son's body.
Like, how are you okay with that?
And she's like, no, it's my son.
He's nine.
So, like, everyone you interact with is, like, all connected
together.
Oh, we're talking about Pluribus.
Like, she made a good point.
He's like, that's not your son.
That's literally everyone you've ever interacted with.
in that boy's body like that son knows what your sex life is
like because it's everyone in that body your husband is in
your son yeah that's why she's like why the fuck do you want
to keep it like this he's yeah he's our son Like that makes
sense.
So I was like, why the fuck are you guys okay?
I mean to be fair Also, the good side is that you could do
whatever fuck you want as long as you're immune You could do
whatever to fuck you want you can request for anything you
want also You want to choose your loyalties with greater
care not let them be decided by birthright
She just toast me the main character just toast me a bit
Like I understand it's like realistic, you know the way
she's acting but still Holy fuck!
What the fuck?
I forgot what it was like to fight him.
I'm sorry.
It's been so long.
I actually forgot what it was like to fight this guy.
I feel like...
I feel like so...
Oh my god, I just went into the fight.
Okay, that's fine.
It's okay.
Oh, no.
Okay, okay.
Um, bottom, middle, bottom, middle, top.
Oh my god!
Middle, middle, top!
That's it!
Okay, I don't know how I survived, but I'll take it.
Okay, okay, that was so risky.
I almost messed up there, but that's okay.
Okay, that's not okay though.
All right, that's fine That is not fine.
Oh my god, that is absolutely not fine either.
That is also not fine Okay Bottom middle middle top Middle
bottom middle middle top I forgot I God.
What's after top?
What's... What's after top?
Middle.
Okay.
Is there anything after that?
Guys, guys, is there anything after middle?
Okay.
Middle.
No.
Okay.
There you go.
I had to be sure.
I did not trust myself.
Are you fucking kidding?
Okay, I literally thought I got...
Okay, it's fine.
I should have just stood in front of him.
Okay, nice.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
That's okay.
Where is he?
There we go.
Oh my god.
He fucking confused the shit out of me
Oh my god, that's fine.
Oh, we did it.
We only used one death defiance You could see what I
foreseen.
Oh
There you go Tooth time now we have two death defiance Did
he know he'd lose All right, yeah All right, tooth time
tooth time It's time to grab the toof.
All right, toof time.
Now we have two death defiances.
Beyond the fires on the heights of Mount Olympus lies the
solitary pathway to the summit on which stands are stronger.
Guys, I have a feeling we might not be able to finish 80s
today.
I don't know.
I can do.
I didn't realize I have to kill him this many times.
I still had to kill him once I planned for one not two not
six I clicked paid it
I got click paid it oh my god what the okay that's on me I
literally messed up there I didn't realize I'd get stuck
like I I was oh my god that was on me I literally got stuck
there I didn't realize this was a fucking court like I
couldn't go anywhere from this corner oh
my god that's close I'm just gonna freeze that okay how the
fuck do I oh my god it's from here okay like i literally
couldn't see fucking shit like how to get over there
i feel like guys head for three up power-ups from bomb no i
could oh my god okay there it is i was like wondering how to
fuck do i dash up there my dash countdown is like off right
now palm palm all right oh my god boss fight right off What
the bat?
Jesus Christ.
That's not fair.
That is not fair.
Oh my god.
What?
Oh my god, I hate this guy.
This guy fucking sucks.
I actually hate fighting this guy so much.
I hate fighting this guy so much.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's okay.
It's not okay, but it's okay.
Are you fucked?
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
This guy.
I just have to do range.
Hard range.
I don't know.
actually press dash that's bullshit I swear to God I press
dash okay like I have to be so fucking far
holy fuck okay okay okay do your thing oh my god oh
someone get him some pants oh my god i hate that guy i hate
fighting that guy so much oh my god that guy was the fucking
worst oh two okay two no that guy was a fucking worst is all
this can't hide from me oh my god this is a this baiting me
like that
it's just all bait
it just oh
are you kidding me oh my god
okay okay that's okay i guess oh
my god that was the only guy okay it's fine it's not fine
but it's oh my god and another boss okay guys i might lose a
death defiance here i have a feeling okay pervert moon okay
complete my thing i could complete it but i could get more
hp Moon?
Okay.
Moon time.
Oh.
Okay.
And you remember to let...
Oh my god.
I try to remember how to fight this one.
Where is he?
What is he doing?
Oh!
Where is he?
Okay, there we go.
Alright, it's fine.
Oh my god, he fucked my dash up.
He fucked my dash up.
Oh my god, I fucked it up again.
Almost fucked it up again.
Okay.
Jesus Christ, I hate this.
Oh, God.
I gotta get up out of here.
I gotta get out of here.
Okay.
I'm scared of the choppers.
Oh, my gosh.
Don't chop me.
Yeah.
No, no.
okay oh god not the chopper not the choppers okay it's not
the choppers
yeah oh there we go oh my god the choppers are so scary oh
not the choppers
okay we we did it oh my god we did it okay we'll do that
we'll just grab everything oh fucking hell one of the
serpentine tales of typhon lord and father of all monster
kind slash to throw floor after floor of the fortress behind
which the olympians take shelter yeah my damage is pretty
bad right now Well, at least I have the shove!
Oh, please be HP.
Please be HP and Deft of Fires.
Oh, thank God!
Don't fret too much about Potts Palace up there, M.
Old Typhon's big and strong and all, but he can't crush what
he can't see.
Well, not as easily as if he could see it.
Okay, I have a lot of money.
It's not entirely assuring.
So, Lord Uncle Zeus and the rest have concealed the money.
seat of power leaving typhon to direct his fury at this
fortress yep more or less they figured that if we have to
take on typhon and we do this is the perfect spot after all
it's a long way down from the summit a quick way down mind
okay i'm gonna buy the death defiance oh hey food okay i got
double food okay we'll buy food and then we'll buy food
again But we'll buy food again, so we're full HP.
Wait, can we...
Should we get the meter?
Yeah, we can get the meter.
Do we have enough?
Yeah, we do.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Okay, that's fine.
We'll get three.
It's three.
Okay.
Alright.
It's pretty bad.
But I'll get what... I'll take what I can get.
I mean, what else can I, I'm not, I don't need another moon.
I might as well get this.
No, that 30 HP, that 30 HP will fucking save my ass.
I might as well get moon.
I can afford it.
I didn't even realize I can afford it.
All right, we'll just grab everything.
Yeah, more damage for me.
All right, here we go.
Here we fucking go.
I don't feel good I'm fully locked in I'm gonna try and lock
in for this I haven't been doing really good dodges today I
don't know why my reflexes are very slow today
today is just not it are you fucking okay it's okay
I can't cast it are you fucking
okay okay
Okay.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
Why is there so many?
Okay.
Oh god.
That bruised.
Oh fuck.
Oh god.
i got so scared not the brood
okay i can summon though thank god
oh god oh god yes
olympians let's give him everything we've got that'll soften
him for you
oh my god
Oh, no, not these, not these.
Protect the palace, everyone.
Oh, what are those?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no.
Oh, my God.
Oh, we saved him!
Oh, my son!
Come over here!
Who's a good boy?
Oh, he said.
We don't, we left him to die.
Okay, never mind.
We never came back for him.
Oh my god.
I can't believe that was the run.
Jesus Christ.
That one was a scary one.
Oh my god.
We didn't even have to use a death defiance, guys.
Come over here.
That's right.
You did it.
You did it for mom.
Many eyeballs for the wind.
and look at this place jesus christ the summon did 60k
damage it was the key with clutch
thank god right five more oh yay yay we made it to the
palace of zeus
my summons did more damage than my fucking entire fight
that's so sad bro he's doing prime the pronda bro I just I
was just there as bait I just had to live long enough for my
summons to do everything else it's so beautiful so pretty I
did it guys Oh my god.
Okay.
Everyone loves to be naked for some reason.
I mean, if you have the body, you gotta show it off, I
guess.
I don't know.
Oh no, I did.
I saved the world.
Surely I don't have to do it five more times.
You have our thanks for seeing to it that the monster Typhon
failed.
to reach us here and you have our regrets that my lord
husband left you to confront that horrid creature on your
own most of the others are still fortifying the palace
forgive that's true less laundry there's nothing to forgive
queen era i am honored to have met you and king zeus face to
face and seen the glory of olympus firsthand i owe it to
your generous support these many nights come now melina we
we have a shared objective after all And so long as Kronos
sits upon your father's throne that objective will high five
I don't understand I will say I'm not a fan that they padded
it with five Like because I have to do Kronos six times and
then typhus typhoon five At least our enemy shall be back at
our gates before long I don't think I can remember anything
roads she may have thoughts on how to rid ourselves of both
our great foes at once we shall find a means of that i have
no doubt and until then we shall be better prepared to meet
their charge yeah i've beaten him six times six seven as you
can plainly see sorry He's don't unsubscribe.
I got the emo for Soldier, by the way.
Perhaps soon enough.
You did it, Sunshine.
I did it.
But the truth is, I had an inkling of doubt, especially once
I saw Typhon for myself.
He was quite large.
I'll give him that.
It's a pleasure to finally meet you face to face like this
cousin.
You play most beautifully.
it was beautiful oh anything to take our minds off of what's
happening at least you bought us a bit of reprieve so i
could yeah typhon is going to be back though isn't he yeah
back for five more times
five more times now i had better go my head mistress can't
you just contact her by boone i'll bring one fourth for you
in case that works and thanks for everything cousin that's
for you i'm unaccustomed to being on this side i see arabus
i think wait headmistress is that you can you hear me hello
in the name of haiti's olympus i accept this message
millennia if you can even hear me yonder i bid you to return
i just got here i worked so hard I fought so hard to be
here.
I'll return.
Why can't I stay here longer?
It's so clean.
There's no random trees everywhere.
It's so clean and bright and gold.
No.
So hold on.
How is it you're going after the time?
a sleepover with my friends guys i'm sorry he doesn't trust
you guys she said i can't hang out with you guys no more
he's just sending his legions there he has a dangerous
commander leading the assault a different titan called
prometheus a different titan called prometheus prometheus
you don't remember who prometheus is yes the titan of
foresight even you probably know the tale of his punishment
for stealing yeah he gave you us fire no it's i think oh she
has history with him you sure she has history okay oh plus a
thousand i like that that's a lot oh look see she's not here
look at that i beat her and she's not here anymore guys look
at that What to cast?
Grants one twindler.
Okay.
Come, spirits of the dead.
I have a task for you.
So, moat it be.
Yeah.
Should be a nice quiet spot to catch a river den as much
here.
Oh, we can fish now!
Okay, rage of elements.
wait let's go fish oh that's what it was locked for it's the
fishing pier what the fuck was it so dangerous to fish here
or some how do i fish here excuse me i unlocked this
lamentation flows through the river coquitis yet even in
such hopeless waters certain creatures learn to live and
thrive i do sense some of them want out excuse me how do i
fish oh i have to unlock oh my god it's a dating oh my god
what i spent my word on a fucking okay
that's fine oh yeah i won't buy well i need to buy fates of
fabric over this okay i'll buy this some fate fabric all
right Wait, what's this?
Oh!
I should grab this.
What if I'm alone?
Why can I solo fish?
What do I need another person there for?
Just give me two fishing rods and I'll fish for myself.
Does it matter if I keep fishes?
Do the fishes matter?
Or can I just, like, Sell all of them.
I'll buy nectar too since I'm rich right now.
No?
Okay.
Just buy this then.
Okay, it don't matter.
Sorry, now you're gonna go get eaten now.
Okay, I saved all of this for money.
Now, oh, should I buy?
What is this?
Restore it with Shades and Others?
Oh!
This is like...
Oh, okay, I should grab this.
Oil.
bounties of the earth grant what i seek so moat it be it's
all right i don't need to look at it everyone please enjoy
all right now you guys can finally eat it took a while took
a while but i did it i thought their taste is fine yeah but
at least they give me something at least they give me
fucking drinks it's cooking still okay i need cook okay your
victory against typhoon have you there anything to show for
it any sort of specimen wait i can upgrade pets how do i
upgrade pets i hope you like hideous eyes headmistress is
there an incantation that you have in mind requiring such
filth perhaps hold on to all of that for now but when the
time is right we shall turn all that monstrous Oh, I need
more pets?
I still have stuff to fucking farm here?
Oh, I don't know.
Put this in.
Grow, my child.
It would be false of me to say I had no doubt you would,
though.
I'd only a bit, I swear.
So how did you outsmart him?
I hired a guy.
All I could do was keep hitting him with all my might.
Yeah, I hit him guys.
Yeah, all me.
The minion never came back to tell his story, so I took
credit.
Well, I mean, if the minion is dead, no one else can know
the truth.
The truth dies with me.
Yeah, what minion?
Yeah, it was all me.
no promises what minion guys what what's the fuck is that
commander what is that yeah I can finally up oh I can't I
need another shadow oh my god they're used up all my
ashments will grab the ash now we vanquished Typhon at least
for the night my lord Hermes ensured that I was well
supplied plenty of gold for you lately all right i gotta buy
ash here you are oh i need like 40 i'm gonna as well bat it
up there you go
oh my god i can't count okay 50.
all right here we go all right 50 guys 50.
Random, inactive.
Whatever.
You activate three.
Activate no more than three cards!
Okay, that one was you.
That one.
Oh, wait.
I have insight.
Alright, what do we upgrade, chat?
Okay.
What should we get?
This one?
Alright, we got it.
Is there anything else we can upgrade?
I can grab this.
I mean, it's a shadow.
Persistence?
Which one's persistent?
Do I have that?
Am I using it?
I am.
Oh, okay.
We'll grab persistence.
All right.
That's good.
We're good to go.
Yeah, we don't need to do any of that.
Your myriad accomplishments thus far are nothing in
comparison to that which you now stand to gain.
young one eternal glory can be yours if you but prove your
worth the patterns on that drapery the secret gifts of the
veil bestowed on nights most dedicated servants commander
what are they doing here shades are never to look upon them
yeah well let's just say the rules have lately changed those
gifts as you refer to them are yours to earn provided you
can do the stuff the oath of the unseen would ask of you
which as you probably surmised shall be no simple feat time
for glory perhaps ahala of greed and arrogance that's the
wrong european country come on don't be such a baby peak i
mustn't look but i wanna i wanna look all right let's see
should we try moments or keep with Cersei guys what do you
guys think I mean I could upgrade this what do I need I need
what do I need to upgrade it what secrets lie within I need
Endmare I need this observe the pitch black stone Momus?
All right, we'll try Momus.
We'll try it.
All right.
I was like, do I keep the frog?
I was thinking about it.
All right.
I'm thinking.
Oh, yeah, I wanted to go to the bar.
Where the fuck is the bar?
Well, where are they?
Where are they hanging out?
Oh, this is where they're hanging out.
Oh, hey, guys.
Fleeting is the sense of hope or joy within the Crossroads
yet what little may emerge is often concentrated in the
small tavern of air No time to unwind Um, where is my free
drinks?
I used my hard-earned money to open you a bar Where the fuck
is my free drink?
Wait, excuse me.
What's the point of spending money if I don't get anything
in return?
But where is my free drink?
not have a tab i funded this all right let's go in oh wait
is this good what should is this good for moments do i go
with keep with Zeus
equip Hera what the fuck is Hera is
Zeus good with uh Hera oh Hera or facade oh the god Hera I
forgot about her.
Which one's better?
Hera is good with...
Okay, Hera.
Okay, we'll do Hera.
The goddess.
Sorry, I forgot about her.
Alright, we'll do Hera then.
What would be good to build?
I guess, like, charge moves.
More to be done up here.
Alright, Hera getting teased.
Yay!
Pleased to have finally met in a more proper way, my dear.
You bought this mountain of ours a bit of extra time, so we
are bolstering our defenses as best we can.
Thus, I'm beseeching you.
I always forget Zeus's way.
I think everyone does.
That's why Medusa got turned.
cast and flicks hitch and immediately deals damage based on
food even Zeus yeah even Zeus forgets his wife yeah even
Zeus forgets we want to which one or should we keep it just
take anything yeah but which one do we take All right I'll
try rush
I didn't remember did oh whoa that was fast chaos right off
the bat
Them some flux Yeah, we got early chaos presents a
significant problem for the Olympians and now also for you I
am not necessarily expected he and Kronos to join forces
Perhaps this is why I could not Detect Typhon's reawakening.
Your 33, your attack's still 42.
Oh my god, I don't know.
120 seconds?
Two?
Do you guys think I can do it in two though?
Yeah.
I gotta go really fast.
But I will try.
Let's see how this goes.
The ancient and obscure originator.
of creation yet remains observing from within such black and
penetrable depths the endless toil of the living and the
dead okay this is witness to all i'm like scared does it
start counting when i go into the room or when the encounter
starts square guys does it count when i'm in the room guys
uh does it count when i'm here in just exploring or when i'm
in a room with enemies
it's going Oh, okay, okay, that's scary Okay, I gotta figure
out Moon, moon, moon, moon, moon, moon We'll go moon first
Oh god, oh god Okay
Okay, I'm trying to kill as fast as I can
Okay Okay Oh my god, okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
That's a risk.
It's better than losing 500
It's better than losing 500 It's better than losing 500 Your
headmistress and I always knew of your potential Now I have
witnessed you live up to it and more The choices Oh Here Oh
god, oh god, oh god, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Bats, bats, bats, bats, bats, bats.
Okay.
Uh.
Hera.
Shambla's ahead.
Okay, that's fine.
Guys, I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm gonna make it.
I'm very worried, guys.
I'm not feeling so good about this challenge.
Hear me on my authority.
Okay.
Oh, wait, two, right?
Or three?
Two?
Two, okay.
I felt that.
Oh wait, but there's this.
It's fine.
Wait, does this count as an encounter?
Oh, I don't know if that counts as an encounter.
Okay, go, go, speed, speed, speed, HP, HP!
Oh god, oh god, it's fine.
I got lost, where are the people?
Oh my god, no, Huntress!
Oh, the timer is paused.
My chaos curse subsided.
We've bigger problems on Olympus than we counted on.
Oh, she paused the counter.
Okay.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
I was freaking out.
Okay, I did it.
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
We actually got saved.
Oh, we got saved.
You were tracking nurse me perhaps but if it's any
consolation finding time thank you for pausing the timer
bringing him down less so i'll take your word for it my
father's much too proud to call me back to aid in our
defense says i'm still needed here if he wants typhon to
himself so badly he can have him all right uh your specials
me deal but you prime 40 after you dash your moves me deal
Shouldn't two be good?
I dash a lot, right?
Or three?
Which one, chat?
Two?
All right.
Two, okay.
We're going to.
Thank God.
Thank God we survived.
I'm just happy we survived.
That was very rough for me.
I got very scared.
Oh, nice.
Some walking money.
Okay, there is hammer right here.
Nice.
That's good.
Got free money!
Oh god.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh, more money!
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Your attack deal is 50...
Oh!
Wait, that's good because I'm always charging it.
Or do I do two times?
I'm focused more on charge.
Or special.
Wait, one, two, or three?
One?
One.
Okay.
Should head to the main square.
My attacks are mostly charged, anyway.
Yeah.
Makes my moment.
more consistent okay what do we do next all right we have
hef okay i have hef on this side you might not be able to
see it because all right hef zeus hermes poseidon and double
hef or magic we do have magic here hermes hermes and hef
yeah we can only zeus i'll do hermes because everyone says
hermes first.
Okay, Hermes.
Alright.
Jesus Christ, that scared me.
What?
Wait, my magic guy is not...
Where's my magic?
Oh, there he is.
We really caught him, M.
Typhon, that is.
I saw him tumble down the dark side of the mountain to the
bottom and go boom.
Then later saw him slowly get back up and roar more angrily
than ever.
I'd more like to occur except for dodge and daze.
Most foes your sprint and gives you...
Oh, I actually don't know what to get for this one.
Two for future?
Or one.
Hmm.
It could be good.
I need time to attack.
Okay, I'll do one.
One because of the building.
I'm at, because of the casting.
Oh, yeah, and the goddamn balls from Typhon.
Yeah.
Alright, this is the hard one.
I don't know which one.
Oh, wait, free money.
Let's go.
That's right.
Oh, it gave me, like, $5.
That's fine.
Alright, guys.
Look at that.
Someone dropped money on the floor.
Alright, we have Zeus Magic Hef.
Double Hef.
Or Poseidon.
Zeus, because the duo is broken.
If we get the duo, do you think it's possible?
I'm gonna try.
Alright, let's Gamba.
It's Gamba time.
Gamba.
Gamba time.
Oh, that's fine.
Wait, that's...
Oh my god.
Okay, that scared the shit out of me.
Boon again!
Boon!
I forgot about this guy I'm surprised.
Oh, wait, I just realized I didn't have any moons
Oh, no, no, no, no, no deal I don't have yeah, I forgot I
don't even have a Zeus boon Our latest battle with him might
have gone differently if not for you Oh wait, do I have five
I have three I mean, I could build for it.
I have three right now So I could, I just need to grab two
more.
Or do I just get the attack?
I do have three right now, so I just got a build for it.
Three doesn't do much?
Hmm.
I guess I'll do two then.
Three is useless for you?
Okay, I'll do two.
Alright.
Oh, hey.
Extra door.
Ew.
what the fuck hit me okay that like it was so cluttered okay
that's good i actually needed that it was so cluttered
hypnotize see you in the crossroads all right okay yay money
all right let's just wait is there any few money here no
money all right sheep time sheep time oh okay i gotta take
the sip of the fountain and now it's sheep time oh shop time
oh hey we need that actually
hello aries be disrupted for too long so i am ever grateful
for your boatman as i'd not have reached you now if not for
him thank god uh your cast also creates oh when you have
less than your stat tax and special restores oh then only
restores like okay but only restores up to 40 i assume
do it triggers each time moments triggers yeah i guess two
i'll try to use my i need to hold q okay i'll try nexus rush
which one is that give me oh it's a sprint okay uh all right
here we go
i need those dogs back there with my bare hands you know
some guys they tell you oh like oh the forward dogs oh you
did all that you're just another servant of chronos the gods
shall punish you when all this is over yeah what do you know
about it they only care about the I'm just a joke to them.
I mean, you do look like a joke.
Just wash off the eyes.
The fucking nipple eyes, bro.
Maybe people will stop laughing at you if you don't have
nipple eyes.
Like, that's your own fun.
Like, why the fuck do you have nipple eyes?
Oh, God.
Too much stuff going on on my screen.
much stuff you don't like it all right there you go oh shit
that's on me no that's not me that's on me
born again
okay we'll get rid of this you fucking okay it's fine i have
born again there you go yeah
good night good night sweet prince again we'll take a shower
bro that's good all right that should reset my oh hey there
is an old adage which goes one would be wise never to strike
a sleeping yeah I think I need more magic to carefully walk
by but at times wait that's beside Poseidon's son?
Poseidon fucked the Cyclops?
I might make one of Bro, he likes, what can I say?
He likes big women.
Hey, hello, buddy.
Alright, let's grab.
Alright, concave.
His mom was a horse?
Why the fuck does he have one eye?
Horses have two eyes.
Poseidon has two eyes.
What happened to him?
What the fuck happened to him?
Genetically, how does that happen?
Okay, oh nice, I got an octopus.
Or a squid.
Stop questioning the myths.
I just want to know what the fuck happened.
Alright.
Oh, ash.
Oh, I can transform it too.
Let's get rid of this guy first.
Is that it?
Wait, where are the...
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, there he is.
I was like, where is he?
I think not.
All right.
Transform!
Yay!
Demeter!
Thank you, Flower.
Well, you've thrown our enemies upon this mountain into
turmoil.
Even now they attempt to regroup.
But with your continued efforts...
His horses only have one eye, dokey.
Oh, wait, freeze.
Oh, wait.
We want that.
I don't think I'm in the...
We want three, right?
Or do we want two?
Two or three?
Six is a lot, though.
Three is good?
I'll do three.
Oh, okay, cool.
I mean, you were giving me two, but that's...
That's okay.
Almost there.
We almost got it, Echo.
We almost got it.
Jesus Christ.
I am so...
Oh my god, there's just so much stuff on my screen.
Grab house.
Okay, I want to get that over here.
There we go.
Oh hey, Ness!
That's actually what I needed.
born again i am a little confused because i can't see
anything the only issue i actually cannot see anything on my
screen already dead sorry there's some catastrophic storm
brewing at the top of olympus i can't get anywhere near it
what's happening oh i forgot to give them god damn it i
forgot about you wait i just don't have nectar i don't have
nectar i spent it guys remember i spent it to build the bar
kronos awakened the father of all monsters and set him loose
yeah i have to guys the bar was more important yeah it's
typhon since i was young i pray to all of you for safety and
good fortune from my tower oh yeah look i gotta drink oh
yeah tomorrow for the christmas party stream I might drink
in the middle of the stream.
It might be beer o'clock time.
Alright.
A plus 10 and plus 2.
Seven encounters?
Okay, this is going to be worthless though.
Oh!
Okay, no, we're not doing acid.
We're not doing acid.
We'll do one.
I think all of them are pretty bad.
I think one is the only one.
Yeah.
We need to get moon.
Oh, moon is good.
I mean, I guess one is good with the upgrades.
Boom!
And then I'll do this.
Alright, let's see.
Nice.
Oh, hey, there's moon there!
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Moon or magic, guys?
Because I know we need to upgrade our moon, but we also need
more magic.
This is hard.
Do we commit to the moon or do we commit to the magic?
Magic?
Moon for money and more healing?
Oh, it's split.
It's so split right now.
No, I can only get one.
I'll do a magic.
Ugh.
I'm gonna do moon.
I'm doing moon.
It's way too split.
I have to make an executive decision.
And I chose magic.
Or I chose moon.
Heal too.
Oh, okay, here we go.
Uh...
10 plus 3.
Oh.
That is so much.
Which one should I get?
I don't know which blue I should get.
Should I get Panacea, Zeal, or Concerp, Panacea's my crutch?
Yeah, they're all good.
I only have three, though.
So, one.
I don't know which one to build for.
Bottom round?
Panacea?
Alright, we'll build for the bottom.
Okay.
Oh, hey.
Shaboya!
Hello, Circe!
That awful storm enveloping the mountain of the gods.
Why just the other night it cleared all brilliant moonlight
in its place.
I thought perchance you had achieved what you'd set out to
do.
Yeah!
Yeah, I had to do it five more times.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
It turns out the father of all monsters is not particularly
easy to dissuade.
I don't know who wants his vengeance against Lord Zeus more,
Typhon, Prometheus, or Kronos.
Our Lady Hecatee and you seek vengeance of your own, you've
met Caryptus in the Rift here, yes?
An all-consuming force.
When I imagine vengeance, all I see is that engulfing more.
All right.
Oh.
That's hard.
One, two, or three, chat.
Which would be the best.
One or three?
Three for Gamba?
Gamba time?
I swear to God.
I swear to God, this fucks me over.
Oh.
We're always Gamba, though.
We've always chose Gamma.
Gamma, fuck it.
What do we get?
The Unseen.
Wait, what was that?
Oh!
Wait.
Isn't that for magic?
That's good for my build.
Yeah.
No, I got passive regen.
The depth of her ability.
Whether as a practitioner of ancient arts or as a cook,
Yeah, that's pretty good, isn't it?
Yeah, I don't have to use my board again.
Oh.
Nice.
Got a tree.
Oh.
Nice.
I'll free honey.
Free nectar.
Yeah, but then I don't have to worry about getting more
magic, right?
But doesn't that mean I don't have to worry about getting
more magic, chat?
What the fuck?
What the fuck did I do so much damage to me?
Next bearing.
Alright, let's get...
Palm HP.
Let's see.
Palm?
Palm down.
That's right.
Don't come into my domain!
Okay.
Yeah, I'll grab this.
All right.
Attack steal more damage.
You're cast.
Do I want me grinder or...
Hmm...
Three or one?
One?
One, okay.
Oh, I shot.
Oh, I'm poor.
I didn't... I forgot.
I didn't grab any like money upgrades.
I forgot.
what that was like.
I feel like all my runs have had money upgrades until now.
I mean, I can afford it.
Oh, I can afford Ares and food.
Yeah, duo!
Yay!
Make it the more visually we fight.
Is that not so, dear lady?
We got duo!
It was not I who made this personal, Ares.
Perhaps if at some future point you have your own children
and grandchildren taken from you, then you shall understand
For now, however, you need but to comply.
Oh!
Wait!
And follows even as you...
Wait, what?
And follows?
What does that mean?
Oh, it's cute.
Wait, what does that mean?
Oh, does it, like, work?
Oh, cast is always on me!
Oh!
I guess we'll try it, and I'll grab food.
Oh, I will beat the Blade Fade Blade!
We're gonna let it rip!
I should have got the 50.
I got scared.
I should have grabbed.
I should have grabbed the palm.
It's alright.
I got scared a little bit.
I felt like I had so little HP, but then I remember I had
heal.
I forgot I had heal.
You're stubborn or just plain, you know, not that it matters
either.
The only issue I have to fight close to her.
You're standing between me and my objective, Aris.
Oh, floating.
The point is, sooner or later, you'll come to understand
that's a mistake.
But we all make mistakes, right?
Neither one of us would be here otherwise.
So you ready now or what?
Let's have some fun.
Let's go.
Let it rip!
Oh, shit!
Guess not.
Oh, God.
Okay, it's fine.
Lady Rat!
Oh fuck, where's my frog?
I actually lost...
I like lost track of my frog.
There's too much shit on my screen right now.
I don't know where I am.
That's right!
Okay, we're...
I'm sorry, I actually used to heal.
I couldn't, I didn't, I can't see anything.
I legitimately can't see shit right now.
I think it doesn't help against her.
She's actually so hard to look at.
Oh, God.
Okay, I'll stand here.
Whoa, whoa.
Is she done?
She's done.
Oh, shit.
Let it rip!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Stand over there.
Whoa, whoa.
I'll just stand here.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
No, my cover!
Don't worry.
We got the ripper.
Wait, where am I?
Wait, where's my frog?
Where's my frog?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, my God.
I got it!
I think back!
It's fine.
Oh, I had enough HP for that.
Get out of here.
I couldn't find my tank!
I couldn't find him!
He does like disappearing.
He's doing shit on my screen.
All right, we got that.
It's knuckle bones time.
And then get the fountain.
And we're heading up.
Oh, we're heading up.
Guys, don't jinx the run, guys.
Sometimes it looks very believable.
What the fuck?
I wish I just need fast cast.
And then this run would be like the god run.
Oh, hey.
That is.
We actually needed that.
Alright, hammer.
all right we gotta kill the goat first all
right and then boom okay nice all right there you go gotta
let it rip i gotta remember to let it rip there we go nice i
don't know if my damage is okay i feel like my damage
doesn't feel that good but i can't tell oh channel into your
special and deal oh
two three right
oh it's very solid damage okay three okay we'll do three
such secrets in this stuff all right magic or eris chat boom
all right all right Ares?
Layer it.
That's right.
Bayblade time!
It's time to grind on me!
Okay, maybe like that took way too long, actually.
It's not really a fab that long that took.
Just sat in the corner.
Alright, nice.
All right, don't worry.
It's charged up.
Boom!
All right, there you go.
It's definitely good crowd control, I will say.
Special seal more damage.
Oh, you get a chance to deal.
Chance to deal.
Okay, wait.
We should get one.
One, because my special seal.
is really three is really good really three is really good
i'll try it okay i'll try it i found something oh really oh
thanks tucked away all right uh hermes oh we should do
hermes so we can have faster charge right faster charge for
hermes all right
whoa okay I did not expect all these guys to show up what
the fuck oh my god that has to be the first time they hit me
I've been in this world for so long
oh god no these are the snipers I just realized I just
realized they're the snipers oh get away from me oh my god
I'm healing Where the fuck is my frog?
What the fuck?
Okay, I should...
Oh my god.
Okay, that's a mistake.
I was standing in front of my frog because I thought he
would block it.
He did not block it.
Okay.
I don't have any of that.
What the fuck, Kermi?
I guess three uh Hermes, come on
Yeah, I'm gonna talk to it.
I'm gonna talk.
No, it's fine.
Yay!
Hey!
Have we gifted a nectar yet?
I don't remember.
Go show that shade the way.
Are we gifted Dio a drink yet?
No?
Alright.
it's my one nectar I don't wish to be just some ungrateful
guest I know you have your customs here and I have studied
them so please for all your cheer and generosity yeah take
the nectar it's the real thing we could use every drop that
we can get then here is something for my most distinguished
guests of which I have decided you are one also I didn't
realize they have speeders back then in the old Greek times
damn the greeks were ahead of their times it's perfect here
i think lord zeus i forgot oh yeah he invented disco i
forgot the greeks invented disco that's crazy the rest of
the olympians don't even know that this is going on that's
right baby man which can't explain how you keep stumbling
of these three every festive fog appears which makes you
stronger here inflict oh the oh but the first time they
strike people how much you have becomes a mystery okay wait
two whatever you do don't take three
all right two Okay, more health.
Okay.
I don't have a lot of money right now.
Should I go for money instead?
Because I only have 146.
Yeah, no.
I saw high as my HP and that did not sound cool.
Money or health?
I don't have a lot, so I feel like I should.
Alright.
I just want...
I wasn't sure because I don't have free will right now.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, that is not fair.
Their powers are in the fucking red dust, but my powers are
also red.
God, I hate that.
I must be healed too.
We need moon, though.
We're really low on the moon power.
And also, I have to kill these guys.
I am very scared of the snipers right now.
The snipers seem very scared.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
Oh my god, true snipers!
This is not fair.
I'll heal again.
I know I just used up all my healing, but I'm fucking poor
right now.
Alright, Ares or Pab?
No Athena, unfortunately.
Guys, I don't...
I don't think Athena's coming, guys.
I don't think she likes me.
She sees me as a threat.
Back in one piece, Talos.
Oh, babe late versus babe late.
Oh my god, I have no time to charge anything.
Whoa!
Oh god.
Okay, that's fine.
What the fuck?
Okay, that was bullshit.
AJ, time.
Are you fucking- okay, it's okay.
Okay, that's five.
We'll grab you here.
Oh!
You did it.
What did he take me for?
No more damage, inflict wounds.
Don't I have that?
damage, reflux, spill, plus strike in this location.
When you have...
Should I get one?
Just for the special?
One, right?
Oh, these two don't sound too good.
Peace can wait.
Alright.
I feel like I don't use Bore and Gain a lot, because I had
the recharge.
So I'm gonna do upgrade.
I don't need a recharge.
Has been actually really good for me.
oh my god resisted get away harlot all
right nice oh god now these guys okay i gotta get these guys
away these guys are scary
nice oh my god she came oh my god she came we were able to
repel that monstrous typhoon thanks to your aid Thank you,
Athena!
Thank you for giving me free stuff!
I love free stuff!
There has to be a way to vanquish Typhon utterly, not just
slow him down.
But if slowing him's the best result we can achieve for now,
so be it.
The so-called father of all monsters.
I heard the tales many times, of course, but seeing him...
Yeah, he's pretty ugly.
I get it.
Which was more frightening, even than the thing itself.
Guys, I didn't give me Divine Dash.
Yes.
Okay.
I mean, I guess, too?
Monetary makes you deflect.
I guess, too, right?
Does it work with Held?
Yeah, okay.
Dora is 3.
30% damage?
I feel like 30% damage.
Okay, this is not fair.
This is a lot of people.
Okay, there we go.
A lot of people for $95.
Alright, we get it.
We gotta grab the heal.
What the fuck was he beating up?
Oh god, not these guys.
Oh, shit!
That scared me.
I wasn't expecting these guys.
That's fine.
Oh god, no.
Okay, it's fine.
I think I deflected.
Nice.
Oh, we need... Oh, nice!
Okay, uh...
We want that.
And then...
Oh, we have to build for that, too.
God damn it.
Okay.
Yeah, I have to go for the top.
But, like, will I make it?
Will I make it, though?
Yeah.
I should have built higher.
No!
I did it!
Oh, shop.
Wait.
Will I get in the shop later?
I will, right?
41.
It's 50.
I don't have a lot of money, so I I feel like, ah, fuck.
The thing is, I don't think I need magic.
Because, like, I have the regen.
Yeah.
I have regen and everything.
So I don't need.
I don't need magic.
I haven't had, I haven't used up any of my magic so far.
Let's go for shop.
I just felt like I have just enough magic for all of this.
Alright.
I accept this message.
Oh, hey.
Two, right?
Nexus Rush.
Oh, my God.
My thing is, like, full right now.
Why does it always hitch?
It always gives me fucking hitch.
All right, here we go.
I swear, I always get the hitch move.
Oh, I have to be so close to him.
Do you hear that?
of the mountain even now impressive that you cast him down
before but he shall not rest till the palace of zeus lies in
ruin he'll be destroyed you along with him if that's what it
takes if he were truly unstoppable you wouldn't be impeding
my assent you're buying him time i am it's strange to think
that time can be a limited commodity even for deathless such
as we but no i don't have any
Oh, my God.
I got hit by every eagle possible.
Okay.
Okay, middle, bottom, top, middle, bottom, top.
Oh, fucking, of course he goes this way.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Jesus Christ, you're such a whore.
Oh, my God, I hate him.
Not the fucking ego.
Really?
Oh, my God.
Okay, this is the worst part.
This is the worst part about this.
Okay, I'm, like, not doing well with this one.
Because, like, everything is...
It's red!
Top, middle, bottom, middle, top, middle, bottom.
Top, middle, bottom, middle.
Top.
Like everything is red.
Oh my god, not the eagle again.
Oh, my God.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Okay.
No!
I have to fucking resist.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god!
Okay, so I lost two death defiances.
So I only have one left.
Okay.
Badeblade is good.
But his attacks are red.
I couldn't tell.
I couldn't see his attacks because of the fucking bade
blade.
Because it's just all red.
So I couldn't see anything.
Oh my god.
Don't get hit.
I legit couldn't see anything on my run.
Your honor, his attacks were red.
Is there a way to change the attack colors?
Because, like, I hate how the Ares' thing fucking blends in
with all the attacks.
It's because everything happens so fast so the red blurs
together.
Like, because I have to react so fast, but it's all red.
of the gods.
I wish they'd, like, change the colors attack.
That's all I want.
I think that's the biggest issue.
I feel like, like, um, I honestly, like, this is all red!
Like, which one's my... Oh, my God.
Oh, my God.
Like, in Hades, it wasn't that bad, I feel like.
I think, like, in the first Hades game, It wasn't that bad.
But this in Hades 2, it's so bad.
It's actually like so annoying.
I'm so annoyed with it.
Alright, palm or hair?
I feel like palm, right?
Yeah, the visual clutter is just so dumb.
I hate the visual clutter.
Palm?
It's split.
Guys, why can't you guys be like the high mountain in
Pluribus?
I see more fine line is good.
What's fine line?
What does fine line give me?
Palm?
Okay.
I'll do palm then.
Oh, fuck!
Oh, God.
Not him.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
Oh my god
Okay Oh god
Oh god that's fine I'm just gonna use this
I don't think the bay blade would be good for me
I feel like the bay blade is not as good Are you fucking
kidding?
Oh my god I fucking hate the range for this.
Oh
my god, I'm running out of heals right now.
Okay, it's okay.
There we go.
Oh.
I have only...
I only have...
I only have one more heal left.
Are you fucking...
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, it does for cast.
Wait, I strike.
Because it has attack.
Yeah.
Because it does for cast.
That's good.
Alright.
That's always good for us.
Jesus Christ.
That's red!
It's all red.
It's just all red.
Red.
It's just off red.
Okay, there you go.
I'm going for...
I mean, it gives me one, though.
Oh, I only have one heal now.
I only have one heal, so I don't know.
Yeah, I only have one left.
Will it be worth it, chat?
I'll try.
Oh, my God, not you.
Oh, God.
He's coming.
He's coming, isn't he?
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
He went down.
Wait!
All right, that's fine.
What the fuck?
Oh,
okay.
Oh, what the fuck, bro?
That's fine.
Yeah!
Oh!
Yeah, he's behind me, isn't he?
but how much money do i have left 500 okay i can technically
oh my god thank god oh then it doesn't give me food but
that's okay
oh i can build it oh i built it okay
oh there's nothing to build for it there's nothing to build
for there's no fountain nearby wait maybe i'll get a
fountain okay here you go oh my god here here here there we
get extra we get extra one
wait wait if i get this do i get one more right yeah
yeah yeah okay i'll get that i can also get this too but it
doesn't really matter i'm just gonna i'm gonna grab this oh
my god i got three more i got three more let's go
that's fish
oh my god okay i was gonna say where the fuck is this fish
like a lamprey behold another creature from the depths oh i
was like this has this is the longest all right please give
me a death defiance please i'm so broke please you've been
good for me for so long are you serious the one time i don't
get a Deaf defiance.
Oh my god.
This is okay.
Okay.
I don't have a vision, too.
The palace of Zeus wasn't like any place I'd ever seen.
There is armor.
I don't know how you all could live up there.
I can grab everything.
Which must feel the same about where I'm from.
Well, I for one quite like it, Doc, but I've spent more time
in the underworld than everybody else up here combined.
As for the palace, at least it's kept us safe in all of
this.
Let's keep it in the way.
Wait, can I grab everything?
Calculate for me!
I'm too scared to calculate.
One, two hundred and seven...
Oh yeah, I can get everything.
I'll get Zeus first.
Hear me on my authority.
Okay.
Oh shit okay Oh wait Three I'm always Okay 399 That's enough
right Okay I got P first too
I'm back Alright we're gonna grab the heart And then grab
food
And then armor There we go gas deliveries risked by swift
hermes okay oh my god i gotta lock in oh my god i'm not
feeling very confident i will let you guys know i i i'm not
feeling very confident because it's all red and then the
there's the gust is also red i this all his attacks are red
so So I am I'm a little worried there about that Just a
little bit Just a tiny bit Oh my god Oh my god That's a
little dot fair Are you fucking kidding?
Okay it's fine Okay
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
What are these attacks that he's using now?
I swear to god.
He did not use these attacks before.
Okay.
Yeah, where is it?
Oh my god.
Oh.
there he is already forget about last night monster okay
okay all right it's five oh my god oh my god okay that's
five
oh god Oh my god.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh god.
It's fine.
Okay.
Are you fucking kidding me?
He's losing his grip.
avoid the spines
no more mistakes this is bad where's my minion oh this is so
bad this is so bad
he's so stressful I don't know he's so fucking stressful
guys I don't know if I can I'm strong enough for I don't
know if I'm strong enough for four more times, chat.
I do not.
He truly is the worst one.
If only Zagreus could see me now.
He is the worst boss.
To all my family on the mountain, let me pass.
Just he gotta be strong, dokey.
Just be stuck.
Yes.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
There's so much pain.
There's so much pain fighting him.
Music.
The majestic palace of Zeus stands resolute and strong.
For the combined might of the gods has kept that seat of
power safe.
Even from such monstrous adversaries.
What the fuck you need me for?
You're gonna be safe anyway.
You don't even need me We got that monstrous fiend once more
young lady thanks most certainly to you such courage in the
face of catastrophe and our palace remains safe and secure
and further reinforced should typhon try for us again It's
so safe anyway, can you let's go.
How about fight him?
But he's kind of ruining the vibe, you know in more ways
than one he's like don't worry olympus is very safe after i
killed typhon it's my pleasure to have been of service to
our family queen hera there's like yeah but he's like
ruining the scenery and like over the property value and
what do you have in mind on that account our own research
has yet to yield the force that could take typhon without
also taking this entire so and then he think it was richard
thinking just long ago i know at the us super chat they can
think you better not cry you better not cry you better not
cry you better not cry santa claus is coming to town i've
gathered useful specimens of typhon's flesh and we've been
studying how we can use it in our craft but we don't yet
have meaningful progress to share oh he's messing up the
garden more than once his progress meaningful Lord husband
thought that your first such victory could have simply been
a fluke what the fuck I like how we hear just Apollo fucking
belting it out while they insult me but now you've
demonstrated otherwise Melina we and spurred our hope that
we shall rid ourselves of this foul menace soon enough King
Zeus Queen Hera by your leave I ought return with what I
found in case it leads to new discoveries about how we can
do just that thank you all for your continued all right i
did it apollo it's good to see you again cousin just as i
was beginning to fear my song would be tonight's sole source
of cheer because i don't know if i could do another one i
swear fighting typhod ages me like he's so stressful his
entire arena is stress but they couldn't leave their posts
please accept our apologies and let us help you to return oh
my god take me home everyone i wish them well i don't know
if i'm strong enough for now everyone may you be safe and
well when next we meet return to shadow now all right we did
one one with wait did we want both friends with Momus or one
with Cersei and one with Momus.
Alright, I don't know which one I still like more.
Momus or Cersei?
I wonder.
Did the weavings of the fates foretell that I would knock
the father of all monsters down the mountain last night?
One to one.
Can they give us super chat?
Thank you.
I'm dead.
It's over.
What the fuck?
She won.
She can't keep getting away with it.
As such, the weavings of the fates tend not to be precise in
their detail, which I know can make them a bit confounding.
I salute your victory, Princess.
I'd like to thank that I, fortunately...
No, I thought I'd finish this game by now.
Because I thought that, you know, I...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, she's still here.
Alright, give me my nectar.
Hello, where's my nectar?
Hello?
I built you a bar!
Oh my god.
I'm gonna grab my fucking shadow.
This should be possible.
Oh.
I got a lot of free stuff.
Okay, it's not really free, but where you may restore
some...
Where's Tart...
Oh, wait.
We don't need Tartarus.
We don't need to go there.
Uh...
Those who re-engrize the gods on...
Oh!
Wait, that's good.
Yeah, rage up.
elements we
need okay we'll grab we'll grab the rage of elements of gods
and goddesses upon olympus fight so might it be okay i'll do
one more run guys i
actually guys i'm gonna call it here i i know i know i said
i'll try and finish haiti's but i i Soon, I had, I have to
tap out because tomorrow is 11 hours stream.
And I do have another stream tonight, chat.
Yeah, we do have good night, chat, chat.
And I have to tap out.
I don't know.
I, no, no, no, no, no.
I didn't clickbait anyone.
You want to know why?
Because.
Oh, shit, give me a sec.
see it you guys you guys didn't properly read my title see
look at that you forgot what guys look at that you guys
didn't read my title it's not clickbait chat it's not it's
not clickbait guys see you just misread the title everyone i
killed Live twice, guys.
Also, I realized, I realized that, like, I do have an
11-hour stream tomorrow, and Photoshop!
What do you mean you screenshot it?
That's Photoshop!
The title was always, I didn't finish game today.
That, yeah, you just misread.
Everyone, it happens to everyone, guys.
It happens to everybody.
Anyway.
Anyway, I'm gonna call it here because we do have uh another
stream tonight.
We do have a good night Dragon tonight and we have a nine
hour stream tomorrow.
I love it.
Sorry.
11 hour stream tomorrow So I feel like I shouldn't uh push
myself too hard.
I do have to prep a lot of stuff too for I still haven't
finished prepping for a 900k celebration or the stream
tomorrow.
So I want to focus on that too.
Um, Yumi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We might as well just do the good night stream now.
Please take care of your stuff and your voice.
Thank you, the super chat.
You mean thank you.
I'll see you guys all tonight.
But if I don't I hope you all have a wonderful Christmas Eve
with your family and friends and a good or a good night's
rest If it's the other side of the world right now, you're
gonna head to bed Thank you all so much And also Merry
Christmas to the people on the other side of the world as
well Thank you all for coming I will finish the game next
week I just did not realize that to fight that fucker six
times I went in thinking oh, I just gotta kill him once and
then I gotta kill grandpappy And that should take like four
hours at maximum I was very wrong.
I was very, very wrong.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, foster
check, get up and move around and get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, guys, you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.